semble pour moins deux heures je dis
bien moins parce qu'à mon avis ça risque
d'être un peu plus le championnat ici
est repris ses droits pour ce soir c'est
un peu pâteuse bx j'ai envie de dire on
va parler collège basket ball en
commençant à analyser les prospects des
conférences hi-media or pour ce faire je
suis accompagné de nos membres
historiques bene allen bonsoir messieurs
comment allez vous
salut pierre saby toi ça va nickel à la
mer très heureux d'être à plat
on s'installe confortablement on ajuste
son et on va rentrer dans le vif du
sujet car le programme quand je vous dis
très chargé on va parler d'eux est ici
de patois depicts web de big liste de et
6,6 et de big ten on finira par une
progression avec les coups de coeur de
bn et alan pour planter le décor quelles
sont les particularités messieurs de
cette saison ainsi et 2021 2022
premièrement way premièrement il est les
transferts ont jugé tellement transfert
pas que des transferts maintenant comme
ça avec la grâce à cause de la colline
font en sorte qu' il n'y a pas d' année
n'en suis pas eu pendant des ruptures de
digue à part donc les joueurs
comme tu parles genre je vais viser un
peu mes joueurs pour le podcast et je
m'étais rendu compte que kader richmond
est transféré de turcs use à
624 sache tous absolument c'est dans la
même conférence en plus je crois est
vraiment très intéressant parce que
c'est un joueur qui était prêt
qui était très sa pointe aux roches ou
et ça ça pourrait quitter très construit
par le contexte
lorsqu'on ce contexte très particulier a
serious man who il se serait servi une
peur de transfert lancé à gauche à
droite difficile de suivre
ouais allen qui contient de quoi toi
je trouve que c'est pas que spécificité
à cette année mais depuis quelques
années je trouve qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gros mc en fait mon la saison
une sieste de coupons de l'otan voire
trois temps si les gens se croirait en
fait de novembre fin décembre souvent
c'est l'émeute or conférence est
certaine on avait souvent beaucoup de
matchs qu'il est souvent avec des
grosses des grosses équipes de bonnes
conférence contre des petites équipes de
moyenne conférence est souvent
l'adversité d'été peg énorme donc pour
scouter des prospects s'était pas
toujours ce qu'il y avait de mieux je
suis encore en poste depuis trois quatre
ans il ya de plus en plus de gros matchs
étalés tournoi là cette semaine c'est la
semaine des tournois à huahine
battlefront entier ni l'autre tournoi et
les grosses équipes se joue en fait
c'est super cool de voir texas a déjà
gagné les jeux villanova ici elle va
jouer à duke du wagon saga il ya le tout
les petits tournois où ils font il ya
quatre équipes à ce que gagne avec
soutiennent y avait eu aussi peur du
tennessee et
vilanova posant même tournoi il ya
toujours le premier le premier jour le
port la forêt kentucky michigan state
kansas et duke qui joue et ça c'est bien
dès le début d'avoir ces bons matches là
pour pour évacuer les prospects et ça
met tout de suite dans le bain c'est
c'est de mieux en mieux roy dir weh
grosse vers aussi contenir aussi est
aussi les super seniors oui cette année
c'est un peu la particularité donc les
seniors qui ont eu la possibilité de
faire une année supplémentaire donc une
cinquième saison donc il ya des équipes
avec des joueurs relativement âgés
loisirs on va attaquer tout de suite
messieurs on commence par la haine ici
donc là ici si ces asu et stern
conférence où il ya entre autres alabama
floride à georges et à van der wiel
kentucky o'byrne arkansas alessio
tennessee missouri olé miss mississippi
state et south carolina on peut tout ça
peut-être non non j'ai triché lui est
obligé complètement tricher sinon sa
peur là j'aurais oublié
et certains autres aussi
on commence par quelques prospects qui
nous intéresse messieurs
commence par le respect ce qu'ils
s'intéressent le plus toutes lettres la
gagne
jerry smith james
oberg hier
mais divine donc j'avais rice médecine
venir de maquillage gérer moi si je me
trompe de 26,8 je veux pas lui voulait
de huit mois deux mois je parle
d'habitude
demain tweed donc 2008 230 ligue c 105
kg entre 405 kg 1
en france donc c'est un cellier fort
probablement il jouit un poste 5 quelque
peu lucie
gros compétiteur
capables de faire beaucoup de
caps a beaucoup de choses différentes
sur le terrain bon finisseur et qui a
pas finir par dessus un anneau en
dessous de la norme on contrôle de son
corps dr
c'est celle a trop plongé pas cessé ces
pourcentages devant moi mais il sait à
trois reprises
dont une au nord avec à l'en-avant le
podcast une proposition à faire rouler
en transition vraiment magnifique il
faut absolument incroyable
bonsoir défensif aussi ses tresses un
peu spectaculaire en défense parce que
physiquement parlant donc le corps pour
rendu à lui devrait être est déjà très
longue et très fines donc une zone un
peu si vous voulez savoir un peu trop à
gauche savoir que trois droites mieux ce
joueur qui joue avec une intensité qui
très très contagieux une bonne une bonne
potion ingle une bonne et une mauvaise
possession eagle pour moi c'est un bon
c'est très bon signe de joie parce que
sa joie qui se perd pas dans sight
pendant un match vous savez le syndrome
tuer s'ils me disent qu'on se met à
flotter sans erreur lui lui fit
connaître jamais seul mois gros gros
fadjri smet là moi je le voulais 5
allen tu es aussi en amour
oui bah
c'était la première fois que je les ai
vus c'était il ya 20 en 2020 21 c'était
il ya plus de deux ans c'était au cubain
n 16 il joue avec la raquette s'était
déjà paristeam challenger n alors je
vous laisse imaginer vous propose les
pauvres pays d'amérique latine ce qu'ils
ont pu se prendre sur la tête et en fait
j'avais rythme et s'était défoulé déjà
trois mois j'ai remis un petit clip
avant le début des années là je rejetais
déjà à trois points envoyez-la cet
athlète fluide et puis bah moi je
n'avais pas trop vu depuis très
honnêtement parce que ils jouaient pas
dans un énorme programme donc c'est
difficile on est tout simplement
difficile de trouver des matchs c'était
difficile de trouver là des matches de
haut niveau lisez mais par contre on
sait j'ai fait les trois matches donc
c'était louisiana monroe de mémoire
south florida et une hotte morehead
state dans cette famille c'est une fac
de farid
est donc alors la qualité de
l'opposition est ce qu'elle est en pas
se mentir ce n'était pas exceptionnel
mais on a vu un
l'arsenal offensif pour un joueur de sa
taille n'est pas n'est pas normal en
fait la capacité à pouvoir déjà de tirer
poser le ballon au sol
et voilà avoir cette influence dans le
jeu défensivement beaucoup de créativité
de la part de bruce pearl qui le place
en en devant danse espèce de zone 1 3 1
où il est là avec ses mains ses longs
segments pour un peu
matériel attaques adverses et conçu des
petites fois qu'on pas forcément super
bon niveau de création sur les bases
extérieur c'était la panique complète
donc attendons de voir un peu plus tard
dans l'année et avoir des bronzes
affrontements mais en fait sur le film
de ce qu'on avait pu voir plus jeune est
ce qu'on en voit un peu maintenant
c'est un top 5 je peux même aller sur
top 3 potentiellement sur sur lui parce
que c'est tous prennent vie recherche
peut-être nuance je sais pas si à terme
ça à terme ce sera 1 5 mais je pense que
comme jerry jackson ne sera pas tout de
suite
il y aura peut-être des soucis face au
gros bon intérieur mais par contre vu
qu'ils tirent il pourra te permettre de
jouer avec un hôtel qui peut pas tirer
donc sur la versatilité elle sera mise
en avant là donc je pense qu'il va faire
rêver tous les joueurs tous tous les
front office d' équipes qui ont
peut-être déjà qu'ils cherchent à
l'intérieur sur la prochaine ronde est
ce que une pensée pour antoine qui nous
parlait régulièrement des hanches ou
tout ce que vous trouvez pas qu'il a un
petit peu léon jouhaux de ce garçon
il ya eu neuf ans le x1 et
force mettre enceinte défensif qui est
absolument incroyable
le gol et gol jamais pris hors position
défensivement mais oui josé petit succès
à la maison c'est quoi le problème des
roches hôtes simple lorsqu'on a des
langes des ongs jambes et aidée en
chauffe ont toujours on est tout va mal
défensivement par défensivement c'est
toujours ça en fait lorsqu'on a un duel
tout le joueur le plus beau le plus près
du sol qui gagne lui jouera les eaux
chaudes plus un problème mais un autre
et j'ai aimé chez gerry smet ou est ce
qui se dit je t'aime mais compense pour
ça c'est que c'est un joueur comme il
était bien en défensive puis qui propose
justement les choses personnelles c'est
à dire souvent mois dans l'épreuve
contre la montre au lait vue on pense je
pensais qu'il s'était fait battre puis
je suis simplement dit gilles son joueur
son coéquipier il n'hésite pas du tout
voiture de ses coéquipiers facilement un
communiqué un bon joueur d'équipé donc
oui allez hop hop mais surtout qui
conscients que les hanches autres puis
il conscient de ces deux faiblesses
défensivement et à cet âge là c'est
quand même incroyable
elle aurait complètement
enfin mis 2 jours fossil pas
pareillement nba
jabari smith senior c'est d'être s'était
pas jean-marie smith et juniors et
jabari smith 2 comme on l'a vu ça
j'aimerais ça mais c'est tout d'ailleurs
si vous le cherchez sur le site
envergure j'ai juste mis j'ai le gérant
est monsieur je suis fier des deux mais
je voulais pas casser en béton soit
retirée sur lancers
c'est ça et donc
oui oui ça peut être un problème mais
personne n'est parfait en réalité
personne n'est parfait un stage la cdc
center on voudrait quoi qu'ils fassent
2008 qu'ils puissent un peu poule up
ayant même temps et puis ce switch et
surtout et qu'il a une mobilité soit
super
forte voilà les gars c'est quoi c'est
kevin durant tout même un peu plus je
pense qu'il faut aussi un peu revoir on
peut revoir il ya la normalité a été en
partie on va dire et c'est normal et
règlent par le cir extrait par le tir
extérieur rennes par sa tête il va
t'amener on pourra le mettre avec un
intérieur qui est pourra se charger
peut-être de switch peut-être de
protéger la peinture connaît de prendre
les rebonds et lui il pourrait être
autre chose ça sedan la première année
avant que lui et prennent du coffre et
que son corps change jamais le corps des
moines mobley on peut changer en nba il
n'y avait ni eau chaude tu compares quoi
mais emploi qui est trop de problèmes
des franciliens
d'ailleurs question
surgit barry smith comment au projet
dans l'échelon supérieur pour l'instant
85 entre les deux requêtes 25 après
ces insectes d'abord et avant tout choix
qui va jouer cinq dans certaines
situations
plus mal un peu plus rapide peut jouer
très très rapidement et aussi les
nôtres dont on parle encore si l'on
rende à nous revoir de cette taille il
est capable de mettre le ballon dans les
pieds capable de est capable de battre
son home of the bands pissos c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui vont lui
servir
vraiment quelque chose qui doit lui
servir en bis - moi je crois qu'il veut
jouer tout d'abord en poste 4 parce que
je il est sa capacité à bouloc sa
capacité comme en défense mancelle ses
adversaires s'étaient défensif je crois
qu'il va avoir une bille et une fois que
les gens vont avoir un peu de tonus mais
quant à tim post 5 je pense qu est ce
que tu en prends même
je pense 5 c'est ça voudrait dire que
pour toi c'est ton premier protecteur de
siècle
sa
propre nom
je ne fit pas sur lui pour protéger
l'appareil ou alors sur le du second
rideau avec la lecture il arrive à aix
et bras et tout ça
je pense qu'on attaque ça sera ce qu'on
appelle un 4 donc ça va mais en réalité
c'est sa vie peut t'amener plein de
choses parce qu'en fait si joue avec un
intérieur type brook lopez mal du turner
c'est à dire que tu peux avoir tous les
mecs qui tirent et si jamais ils jouent
avec un intertitre trois nuits pour
attirer donc y aura de la versatilité là
dedans mais c'est 1 1 4 5 hybride plus
sur le poste 4 en début de carrière je
pense
messieurs dames à caen je vous propose
qu'on enchaîne avec l'ami de kentucky
taitei washington junior
netanyahu à washington déjà retenez bien
prénom ça c'est facile
est-ce que allez je vais faire le
mauvais gémeaux est ce que ce sera le
gros minet de la prochaine draft ok
c'est quoi un gros minet le gros poisson
on va dire
ça n'est pas parce que tu as déjà c'est
le prochain goy garde kentucky sous
utilisés mal utilisé oui bah ça on a
presque eu la réponse déjà non
c'est propre
voilà moi très honnêtement je suis un
gros fan de taille
j'avais découvert avec ça après ce coup
là et qu il avait failli battre tout le
monde vers 2 il ya deux shoots au buzzer
au pays qu il le rate mais il est super
fort il existe déjà un peu plus un peu
un peu épais par rapport aux autres un
peu plus riches qui s'est affinée il
échoue au niveau du corps c'est mieux
qu'avant
je suis juste frustré je pense que voilà
comme je dis essaie de le dire sur terre
rhizome accès je compare pas où on a pu
dire sur nos jours avant la vraiment
falloir prendre ce contexte qu'une
turquie comme un contexte et panneau en
fer la globalité de syfy washington
j'ai vu deux matches donc j'ai vu suis
contre duke et suit contrario voilà
j'aime beaucoup ça vire wheeler c'est un
bon meneur mais ça me frustre de voir
autant servir wheeler balle en main pour
créer avec à côté
détail qui bat soif est là c'est grâce
au secondaire ça c'est du spo top alors
qu'en fait toute sa carrière avant
c'était vraiment lui quel mal an quel
bilan pour lui ça va pas être simple je
pense sur le début de l'année tout le
talent offensif il est là je trouve que
la création elle est là et
dans une poêle dire dans une cuve
hedegaard pas exceptionnel moi je le
trouve vraiment intéressant et je pense
qu'il a sa place dans cette draft et
c'est un jeu trouvant plus sinaï la
porte il a un certaine confiance en lui
une certaine
qui va bien avec avec savoir faire
acquis parce que ça fait
extrêmement forte chance que j'ai eue
ensemble
quels sont les points forts de tahiti
washington qu'est ce qu'on achète qu'on
ait un scout ndi mais
c'est un joueur extrêmement rapide
capable de jouer érosion est à mi
terrain avec une explosion va battre son
homme du premier pas mais je les ai vus
déjà vu jules et même de le match par un
pied déjà j'ai vu des
jeux j'ai eu des
duels au premier pas était absolument
dégueulasse et les ccis et sont sans son
défenseur dans l'ariège quelquefois
quelque chose que j'aime aussi qui est
très rare de passe et
maintenant qui est de créer de très haut
niveau comme ça ce qu'il a lors de la
lecture facile c'est à dire il va faire
leur simple d'abord et avant tout il va
faire le bassin il va toujours
il peut toujours faire le jeu qui est le
plus statistiquement paix il va jamais
s'embarquer dans un trois contre un et
que jamais il jamais forcer le jury la
lecture simple solution pour moi c'est
c'est une preuve de maturité ce une
preuve de joie que je joue et je mens
dans un plus petit
dans un plus si pas grave ou est-ce
qu'il n'y avait pas de compétitivité un
peu malsain et
c'est là justement moi je me dis là elle
en a bavé comme utah il avait comme
était à crayton est en fait il n'y a pas
eu de suite aux propos un peu traîné
deux mois de cauchemar dermott et
ça c'est un jour qui était un peu sous
recruter parce qu'il était un peu bas
gros en fait je n'ai pas bien super
physique mais par contre tout le monde
le voulait sur la dernière année parce
qu' il est sur une progression linéaire
franchement est ce pour ça que ce qui en
a fait sa quasiment sa recrue principale
c'est le seul fraîchement d'un start et
dans une équipe qui a accueilli beaucoup
de transe quartier
voisin et qu'il était un petit peu de
chevilles ou bois sur les photos de lui
ou lycée
mais si on est déjà en retard donc on va
pas faire plus longs sont altaï on va
mettre leurs pas là on va t'amener en
reparler on va par là bas toute l'année
de taille exactement on va parler d'un
autre prospects un meneur qui joua
telesis et de poitiers c'est qu'inédite
chandler alana auriez bien que vous
apporte le plus demandé dans le chat est
ce qu'elle chante leur quart d'heure on
en pense quoi ici et kyle chandler
murmure des prochaines offres alors
on en pense du bien on en pense du bien
mais c'est rare qu'on a pu voir dans
divers contextes il était à la coupe du
monde et 19 où il était accueilli t bag
meneur
on l'a vu au lycée aussi
scénariste christiaen et là on le voit à
tennessee qui tuèrent
est ce que c'est le meilleur je vais
faire rapidement excusé le meilleur
meneur est peut-être le meilleur
initiateurs je pense pas il est
peut-être trop petit pour ça mais ça
c'est un genre qui jour en nba c'est un
joueur très rapide très vif de questions
là le tir pour être en question à cause
d'une mécanique un peu étrange et ça
porte un peu de bois je suis assez
rassuré sur les primates journée du 2
j'ai vu donc le premier compte soutient
martin du croix et le et le match contre
un match contre villanova je suis assez
rassuré sur sa par contre il est un peu
trop petit pour que ce soit le meilleur
meneur dadraf pour moi c'est parce que
pour être ça fouette il fait mais 83
voilà ma terrasse est petit par contre
ça sera un jour de rotation une pièce a
peut être même être un titulaire nba
mais je sais pas si je laissais un jour
j'aurai dans mon top 10 où voilà la
cause de sa petite taille mais c'est un
super joueur il va domine encore le
masque est bonne parce qu'il est fait
pour 2011 ben
moi j'aime beaucoup aussi
je trouve qu'il est très très que ce qui
m'a marqué avec hannah jenner c'est les
appuis très très solide sur ses appuis
il ne recule pas en défensive
même s'il est physiquement pas très gros
fake 310 kilos et elle s'est
facilement aussi dans les airs au
contact capable de finir c'est un
finisseur absolument
spectaculaire il peut faire son chemin
en trois-quatre ans sort au panier finir
sur le cul avec 2 points est très bon
aussi pour aller chercher des faux très
bons contacts pour chercher des fautes
c'est vraiment ça à son à son
à son fonds de bali à son poids son
gabarit et le choix de faire ça ce qui
augure pataterie carrière de très courte
durée qui va se faire matraquer dans les
raquettes en billets merlin
j'aime beaucoup si ca pacité a arrêté
très rapidement arrêté polop très fluide
jeu
c'est que des gens vont hurler quand je
dire ça comme ça mais
il ya quelque chose
si je compare pas mais quelque chose
d'une qualité que kennedy tchad qui est
un peu car irvine et risque de créer
pour lui-même de créer de façon change
compagnies impliquées mme bauer ça me
fait passer un paquet va voir coeur des
bands année sa manière de 2,2 m pression
sur le panier moi j'aime vraiment
j'aimerais beaucoup je trouve qu'il joue
plus grand et plus gros que c'est que
c'est c'est que ce que son poids et sa
grave oui c'est son format va le
rattraper en nba je crois pas qui peut
qui domine en ce moment comme un mba ou
un calme et un billet ça va être
quelqu'un justement qui va mettre
beaucoup de pression sur le but beaucoup
de questions sur l'anneau comme le
oui est ce que
le contexte est pas idéal pour lui à un
tennis ea dans le sens où il est aussi
associé à un autre meneur on la perd ce
qui est plus expérimenté en la personne
de vescovi
uruguayen je vous voyais en deux mois un
peu plus des charges et de la création
que que d'autres mineurs freshman
a peut-être peut-être ce qui est déjà on
va dire qu'en fait il a plus le jeu pour
que ça fit mieux all you can eat
chandler ça pouvait être pour rejeter
swinger ou kim johnsson l'an dernier qui
on a passé un cap a été très bien mis en
valeur par le coach bande
dessinée avec des gens qui en plus ne
tirez pas de fonds ont tiré peu premium
énormément johnson pas un traître et
mentir leurs personnages j'en ai reluit
batz sur mer c'est plus le genre en fait
qui il a tout pour dominer ok je passe
quel bois je pense et en plus il ya un
peu de ce pays comme j avais sco vie qui
tord baye laye moi j'aime bien le
finlandais qui à côté car moi qui comme
moi voilà qu'il faut aussi mettre les
paniers que c'est une poële un démarrage
ou en termes de transferts delà de
l'année donc oui
le contexte est bon c'est pas forcément
cause des joueurs qu'il a autour de quoi
je parle je pense que c'est peu son jeu
moi qui fais 13 basketball et qui je
pense sera bon nba en contre troisième
garde une rotation au minimum
mission va s'arrêter sur l'a6 est ce que
vous avez doute non à regarder dans
cette conférence vitesse comme ça
j'ai dit les vestes d'alabama
au plus d'être croyable des rythmes sans
doute
le plus incroyable est le manque de
constance le plus incroyable si de
moissac qui me fait beaucoup mais qui me
fait mourir de rire c'est que
présentement des seuls
24% à 3 points mais carrément la moitié
de ces énergies souffert 50%
et la moitié de re qui a fait 250
conseil fait 2 0% à 3 points moi c'est
c'est un lundi
c'est un des
des prospects et plus de 25 cette année
je fais beaucoup
extérieur aspect rien contre lui mais
après ils traiteraient ce qu est un
délice everson molinard mississippi
state
darus days and are used el
adha adam miller qui s'est fait les
croisés malheureusement qui jouera les
insultes robert wells effet les
croisades avant la saison super déçu
puisqu'on trouve un ou deux têtes si tu
veux baala a
le deuxième meilleur prospect de kenshoo
qui en réalité c'est peut-être darwin
collins
c'est leur freshman parce que je pense
qu'il on est très bons joueurs âgés qui
demandent mon prospect oscar tchimou est
peut-être peut-être à suivre aussi à
scarlett politesse ce quartier voué
séjour ces gens là le pivot de l issue
qui vaut à mj comme stone reid et j'ai
vraiment là on parle de rides qui jouait
raï'n'b call centers
djaimin bradfield à holmby hills ouaddou
qu'avant mayron john un flo rida qui
joue à penn state avant
pas mal de joueurs intéressants
conférence quand même assez riche on va
essayer d'accueillir julien j'espère que
sa connexion ça va aller
julien est ce que tu nous entends
perrette lofton julien 51 il joue à
louisiana tech il était son premier
match contre ret la maman il ya beaucoup
de si mais le coup n'est ni vraiment
cédric c'est certain ça va être un gros
scoreur de la division cette année et à
voir on va arrêter d'accueillir lumière
julien est ce que tu nous entends c'est
très bien
que ça dure
non on te voit pas mais on a loupé un
gros cylindre
ma [ __ ] plus fort
julien tu va nous parler de qui on
t'écoute
parker alors harry walker
gdba et walker l'ap actuelle c'est ça
oui
vous trouvez la bonne entente bon ok
je te le dire assez mais si jamais ça va
pas
donc
en fait c'est en
raison du coup il
est court
ça coule pas douce est en fait très peu
l'année dans un procès où il a pu
ce qu'il sait faire ça du
tout pendant trois mois au catch and
shoot
et
pourtant
tu vois
plus gros cette année
j'ai remarqué
[Musique]
wray julia on va se focaliser sur
qu'est-ce que ce qui est vendeur pour
lui pour l'étape supérieure qu'est-ce
que qu'est-ce qui pour toi et le fait
qu'on achète on met un pic de drap sur
ce gala
avec une qualité
c'est très correct
que
dignité qu'on aurait le
cadet
hockey à la db nous l'avait vu le walker
de colorado
je me rappelle surtout de lui dans le
match quand il
a animé tout le monde moi je crois qu'il
ya cinq ou six tirs à trois points si je
perds 100% pour apprendre la journée
pour moi savoir
speak and pop c'est à dire qu'ils sont
capables de mettre des écrans il bouge
bien les allemands capable de faire des
rues queen
capable de ces duos
de la caisse de jours de la glaise qui
est vraiment au périmètre ce qui est
vraiment le 3 et le plus des plus
difficiles ce qui ce qui créera bhl
selon moi des facilement 6-1
d'intelligent qui pour moi je trouve que
les places passe super bien sur le
terrain je trouve un peu l'eau sur ses
pattes mais il compense beaucoup 1
en prenant des bonnes décisions
s'économisant en prenne la bonne
décision sur le terrain très bon
défenseur dead
oui j'aime beaucoup j'aime bien le faire
j'aime bien préférer balewa que je pose
pas les joueurs les plus vues mais j'ai
rien ce que j'ai vu de lui à l'aide
j'ai bien aimé par flash l'an dernier
parce que mais il ya un mec sur super
petit volume qui shoote à plus de 50% à
3 points en tant que freshman sur les
postes 3 4 directement ça attire l'oeil
et donc après essayer cette march
madness ou huawei on voit apparaître un
peu plus
misant mise en lumière il fait le camp
de team usa 8 19 il est que tu n'es pas
dans les douze ans avec un peu dur
changement je pense qu'il ya des joueurs
qui étaient moins intéressante lui qui
était qui et qui ont été pris dans ses
choix de coach après mai et donc je
pense que là cette année dans un rôle
plus important il prend deux fois plus
de tirs il va jouer je pense que deux
fois plus de dix minutes il a tout pour
être un peu le genre de sophomore qui se
forme en régnier phase iii iv qui tire
cas par exemple trop du ballon pour
vivent donc ça c'est super intéressant
je conçois
on enchaîne sur rémy rac et juniors
alors qu'on aperçoit julien s'est lui
bien
on t'écoute sur raquette le joueur de
ucla le dj jee
et 100 dos
des
combattants kg il avait réussi comme
prophète
et non il évolue comme tous trois quatre
ans
c'est ici peut donner des points forts
parce qu'en fait il est tout autre
spécialité
de
volume
il est
fait partie des meilleurs défenseurs de
la
bad robot il a tout dit
les poses de garder les postes
donc c'est un joueur qui
est
équipe le voir jouer
c'est ça plaisir aux
bretons le programme du dossier et c'est
un petit trip hop est dans le sac il
fait partie des
deux
caméras qu'ils n'y a rien qui nous
demandent une question sur le sujet aura
pas en parler ce soir teasing on voit
sortir quelque chose sur doux dingues
dans la semaine donc vous aurez votre
dose de guérilla toujours des makassed
voilà un
article sur lui donc alors après de
johnny de john is using
jeu trop tellement malgré ce qu'a dit
julien c'est difficile de dégager un
point fort ou des qualités plus plus
cher à mes raquettes en fait il fait
tout bien s'en est exceptionnel dans
tout mais un peu plus un peu plus grand
et un peu plus puissants que les gardes
qu'il affronte et ça lui permet de d'un
petit peut faire sourire un peu de bonis
ball en lui même temps il mais il
commence aussi à mettre à trois points
donc sur petits volumes donc ça va ça
reste ça reste important
personnellement pas sûr qu'il ira la
draft
c1 juniors je le vois peut-être rester
pour être tâche pas un des meilleurs
genre de coach de basket ball du pays
peut-être l'an prochain on verra c'est
quelque chose dont qui seront
intéressants mais en tout cas s'il y va
ce qu'il apporte c'est je pense un rôle
player en sortie de banc
qui fera pas de bêtises sur le terrain
qui pourra faire une ou deux choses
assez assez bien et puis regardez ucla
parce que c'est super c'est super fun et
en plus ils ont d énormes matches karim
lô nous avons profité pour dire que le
dernier article c'est justement c'est
sur la fiche qui va y avoir dans la nuit
de mardi à mercredi entre gonzaga et du
célé
pen est ce que ma mère à caissons son
point fort c'est pas finalement son
mindset de guerriers absolue
oui mais je voudrais aussi que sont pour
les français ce qu'on a à perdre un peu
que vous gagnez à une bille est ce à
dire en basket c'est quelqu'un qui
complète un peu qu'ils bombardons qui
complète un peu là où l'équipe en a
besoin on connaît par exemple ouest est
aussi allée où l'homme avec lamia sur la
tête tiger bunny
bons joueurs offensifs qui peut très
hypocrite soral a nous aussi donc
regarder la question le terrain il est
toujours là où il y en a besoin où il va
être au beau d'abord pour aller chercher
un des shows post bas où il va les
mettre aux périmètres
dans un angle il fait tout bien page
comme il fait il ya appris à faire ce
dont l'équipe avait besoin quelque chose
que je me couche de lui un autre point
fort que j'ai couché c'était
physiquement par là même s'il a l'air
d'un facteur il est très fort
physiquement donc on peut lui ne la
balle au poste bas comme des joueurs
sont plus grands plus gros qi puis il va
être capable de créer quelque chose lui
crée de l'espace où il veut créer son
tir le gaillard absolue mais
physiquement parlant être capable de
créer quelque chose au contact pour ses
coéquipiers c'est cela qu'ils ne montent
pas l'appeler fond d'une et kiev est ce
quelqu'un qui montre plancher d'une
équipe tout le monde est un peu meilleur
que quelqu'un comme craqué sur l'autel
un peu comme pauleta wegner à orlando
dépenses
juillet en chaîne avec ton dernier prose
p c'est un joueur de standford je crois
cécilia
alors
c'est compliqué parce que je n'avais
potable
et quand ça tombe bien la vie
m
[Musique]
et
c'est un shooteur à trois points
et progresse ou défendre ce soit qui
prouverait son dribble il n'est pas du
tout mais au début d'un vrai meneur
litige ou pas la passe pas trop où il
est parti il a été dans la nasse l'idée
qu'être mais avec lui il a montré qu'il
pouvait être très bon
il s'y retrouver puisque lui vraiment
petit gars de niveau à stanford très
compliqué pour lui
des derniers tests y ait
un club brille en tête des premiers max
c'est pas facile non plus mais il a par
flash corps c'est tout ils sont notre
pourquoi ce soir c'est moins gênant
c'est sa défense voilà c'est un ailier
qui a des jambes les costauds ils font
quoi
il peut défendre tout ce que vous en
faites vous donne quelques uns défendre
le défend il va tout donner ils n'auront
jamais dit cela il ya des profs minute
en minute avec un tout usage très faible
ce qui tue pas souvent le ballon ils
servent de relais mais c'est un guerrier
il est là au bon offensivement défensif
et il ya un moteur constant pas pour la
vue je
dors dernier match
au bout il se pare d'un tube est au bout
des robots
encore de l'équipe points
alors à l'année oui je vous sais quoi
encore un hindou gaye à la mode dans ce
sens ou potentiels dit oui et non celle
d'un quad on va danser un mec qui avait
pris plus de sept tirs par match sur un
ancien ya pas vraiment d'évolution dans
la prise de tir ou dans quelque chose
comme ça dans son dans son cursus
initiés moi j'avais beaucoup aimé sa
première année comme julien je pense
éminent madame à watch list les joueurs
vraiment à suivre l'an dernier
le contexte a fait que c'était compliqué
pour lui de peser il peut pas créer pour
lui il est dépendant des autres il
dépend du spacing aussi pour pas non
plus et devoir avoir des positions de
tir super compliqué
qui pourrait pour cela je dansais francs
et un peu aînés ne reflète pas vraiment
sombre hp corps humain il vaut mieux que
ça mais ouais c'est un joueur qui
servent aux sceptiques mais je pense que
j'en aurais parlé peut-être de 25
joueurs de pâques preuve qu'ils pourront
faire peut-être plus de stats qui vont
faire plus de choses en que lui mais lui
si messi voilà il met élimé à trois
points alors c'est pas c'est pas un
petit ce qu'ils enseignent chose qu'à
une chose la plus importante mais il ya
ça passait mieux parce qu'il peut
défendre et 3,4 et vivre sans mal
mais un avis sur ce crime sur 12 mois sa
bâche qui rattrape et j'espère que
l'année dernière c'est la pureté du che
c'est très très peur ça va quand même un
cas d'école ça décolle qui sera sa
touche pas là nos îles carte de série en
sortie d'écran cheese que je vraiment
beaucoup
c'est à une hyper spécialistes côté
côté mayence est haute et esprimo l'air
d'un gars le mans qui
comprend peut-être pas quelles sont ses
forces et ses faiblesses mais qui se
concentre sur ce qu'on sur ce qu'on lui
dit de se concentrer il est discret
souvent sur le parquet a pris justement
c'est qu'un gars justement comme julien
le dit ils sont très très puissante qui
est sale et non seulement à défendre sa
live booth si justement à sortir un à
exploser arrivé de manière très très
rapide et très course oui c'est un
joueur sur qui
choque qui garde un oeil c'est je crois
personnellement que ce genre de loi qui
va finir en but acheté des mots sphère
mode il ya toutes les équipes d'albi
parce qu'ils vont finir j'aimerais que
les clippers jamais 40% par match
mais oui moi c'est très très peur
julliard ont fini par towers liste de
gars à garder dans sa conférence
macworld
je ne peux pas dévoiler les nous les
plus importants pour toi regarder
n'était pas tes chouchous
des petits matches
dans les
allées
on a fait un
tabac
yakou locaux
congo vos prospects sur bombe à gladbach
sortir j'espère
hilton du ciel des sceaux sur ma part
tout seul et joue pas ou ne veut pas
trop
aussi
sitôt
et puis moi j'ai noté aussi
apolitique maire
de lefaux d'acheter il était dans les
dents septembre
j'ai rien
d'autre qu'à vous plaît peut-être
mon frère mon plus gros
à la db je voulais laisser compléter
d'autres noms peut-être si des gens qui
nous reviennent me regarde et on part en
pack toile vous côte pacifique tous
n'ont pas cette photo
[Musique]
comment il s'appelle debian harmon est
ce que c'est bon qu'est ce que ça vous
guider les skis dames qui mena une
histoire un ouais j'aime bien vos
billets les soirées quincy guerrier
aussi
sentir accusant et plus exactement
j'étais obligé de lui faire plaisir
oui richardson aussi à oregon
[Musique]
pour oublier beaucoup beaucoup de
transferts donc c'est dur
non mais déjà le regret pas mal on
disait de gaza n'a pas eu la super lice
le lituanien
oui il y a deux c'est ses deux frères
dont un
soldat
génial merci beaucoup on va te laisser
on te dis à très bientôt on va
accueillir une gare un
salut vient saluer
salut les gars commencent à voix basse à
laquelle vit si les pas du tout l'homme
avec la voix la culture phonique d'heure
tu viens de parler tu vas parler
longtemps en plus de ça toujours vu que
je suis un tu as de heim est d'or comme
conference on ne se refuse rien et on va
commencer avec la victoire on est
d'accord bah ouais avec casey avec
clément c'est
là que tu veux la beetle c'est la
meilleure des conférences voilà c'était
place et on va commencer avec celui qui
était de justin bieber à la meilleure
qu'on brûlait on a match au meilleur de
b lors pour commencer par le champion
comme un
match où bella mathieu meilleur excusez
moi c'est un ailier seniors c'est un
scoring machine à rien on parle de
philippe de postiers bon on est là
dedans
c'est un gars qui peut marquer de
partout l'arrivée en frenchman il jouait
pas beaucoup se formeraient joue un peu
plus mais il était très inconsistant
hills et n'importe quoi sur le terrain
en juniors il était leader du bon il a
commencé à voile à avoir de la
consistance de la régularité est un des
meilleurs choix il s'est mis à la
défense et ça serait de devenir
importante s'il veut reconquérir
professionnels surtout nba parce qu'il
la spirale nba cette année il était
censé être le leader offensif de bello
pour l'instant je veux dire pour
l'instant la réussite à l'époque
notamment à trois points il est à 20% à
3 points alors que trois gros volume
l'an dernier il était à 40% à 3 points
mais voilà quand il va à ce qui va
mettre des profanes ajuster la mire ça
va vraiment une scoring machine
incroyable et on peut parler dans un
deuxième tour fin de premier tour si je
peux comparer d'un joueur dont le profil
de ce que veulent les franchises nba
jordan noires à qui sont de louisville
il ya quelques années qui avait fait
aussi des gros projets sur la défense et
sur sa capacité à devenir régulier a
suivi le même parcours et les bucks soit
elle chercher maintenant c'est qu'ils ne
prendraient rotation est-ce que c'est
pas plus impose de bien trier même qu'il
est
disons qu'en nba il ya des tumeurs m6
devenus intelligents et la panne
latéralité incroyable qui est surtout
dans ses rotations et donc il va pas
forcément de tenir beaucoup de profils
notamment lé profil l'extérieur donc que
tu mettes trois costumes 24 en fait il
défendra toujours sur le moment bons
ailiers adverses ne et il sera là dans
une rotation parce qu'ils veulent en
effet des très très bonne rotation venir
attaquer ses choix les mains sous le
panier être en second rideau mais tu le
caches sera toujours sur le moins bon un
peu ce que fait un joueur négocie en
billets c'est un très bon collectif
mais que tu va toujours mettre sur le
moment bons ailiers adverses en termes
athlétique tu ne vas pas rater sa taille
il fait combien de 6-2 8-6 et plus haut
je te re disent tout de suite excuse moi
je
me suis quelqu'un qui lui remet en
jeu 2 6
pour le pire halal on écoute sur un
match mais hier le 1d physiques les plus
improbables dossiers et projets
capillaire extrêmement intéressant ça ça
et ça c'est très important
pas une coupe de mingan contrairement à
web assez
difficile à traduire en français un flop
car devant c'est un floor spacer's
circulent mais sur le terrain il ne
heurte pas trompé singh il peut mettre
ans potter je pense qu'aussi peu attaqué
des clauses à votre peau pour aller
jusqu'aux serre et poser la balle au sol
pour ensuite prendre amis de rennes joue
un truc comme ça il peut le faire vrai
un vrai bon bras
je crois pas que ce sera d'accord c'est
pas le meilleur prospect de baylor non
mais mais
pareil voilà au deuxième tour qu'elle
n'a peur nous
savons c'est même sens que tu as envie
de tenter un truc sur un jeu de scoring
avec 21 tout est sur un joueur comme ça
comme ça peut se faire dans certaines
franchises ça peut vraiment ça peut
attirer parce que le mois il est né là
ben
moi j'aime beaucoup m meilleurs soient
très étrange singera quitterait qui a
été très sensibles une autre année de
faire partie des obsessions de ben
très très lent extrêmement lents comme
joueur mais qui justement capable de
gérer un peu l'accélération la
décélération au shooter comme vous
l'avez dit étrange un bond passant au
large du port et comme le notait comme
s'il est souvent
on met souvent le moins bon défenseur il
détecte le moins bon des forces adverses
parce qu'il est pathétique parce qu' il
est là il va souvent capable de passer
le ballon par dessus la défense adverse
et moi c'est une qualité que j'aime
vraiment beaucoup chez un joueur je
garde jeudi dès cette année il fait il
fait pour ça avec l'eau m'a donc ça
c'est un très grand plus pour moi mais
notre que j'aime chez lui que malgré les
limitations physiques l'ont un peu ce
petit guéridon l'heure de défendre avec
gelée vu se faire tourner à 360 degrés
revenir et mettre la main quand même
dans le visage
même si le tir enroulé non cette rs 2
angles
a va être payant pour lui avec payante
cj le daily star défensivement ce joueur
là et ça fait de lui le roi qui je crois
va être au pire
point noir outre ambiance et je crois
que j'ai trois potes qui avec l'équipe
jusqu'à un certain niveau je crois pas
qu'il va être un - l'offensive je vois
qu'ils essayent beaucoup trop fort pour
pour être un jour négatif défense ils
ont gardé pour un article sont
essentiels son indice de production il
était plus 27 quoi
hugo va enchaîner avec le prospect de
kansas ou tuer jésus moto hameau de ta
femme
au chalet akbar j je te laisse nous le
décrire
je vois juste sache que je t'ai vue de
les commenter avec je prends sur moi
pour toit pas je prends fort sur moi que
j'aille akbar dit bah oui je suis
totalement un mot du jour l'an dernier
déjà quand il était junior donc là cette
année les seniors eux étaient de kansas
l'an dernier 10 ans parce qu'elle allait
à la draft
il fait un mètre 87 ils étaient 96 kg
qui prétend qu'il est vraiment pour le
coup il est prêt à aller au nba une
envergure 208 cm c'est pour moi et mes
yeux le meilleur swing 10 des
championnats universitaires pour
l'instant
très fort dans le dans le cas de
backdoor ils montent très haut il écrasa
tomar sur absolument tous c'est un
énorme bosseur il a connu différents
rôles lui aussi il arrive en 1ère année
c'est pas du tout nouveau prix de côté
il ya été bonne dose funky manaudou en
d-league tu as one thing ramenée ensuite
à transférer dès maintenant jouer aux
knicks tu as même mccormack le pied vos
actualités trucs beaucoup plus côté il
arrive un petit peu dans l'ombre
première année joue pas 2e dan et très
peu troisième année de vienne deuxième
option a coûté de marcus garrett et
cette année c'est la star de l'équipe et
les jours des débuts assez incandescent
le monsieur donc donc voilà je pense que
c'est un joueur qui
après la fonte de l'autre il a pour
l'instant je commence déjà à l'envisager
tu peux fille dans n'importe quelle
équipe mais j'ai fait une hotte tech
dessus des objets de la tenir je pense
que sur une fin de premier tour
si un mec qui doit devenir all stars je
parie sur lui dans un style style jimmy
butler et c'est dès ce qui progresse
tous les ans ce mec-là fils il ya passé
son été à faire du foot fin du soccer
parce qu'il voulait trait sur ses
fondamentaux de pieds carrés de kansas
de soccer il s'entraîne et balle au pied
avec eux pour justement travailler ça
donc ça mec qui s'arrête jamais
est ce que vous êtes aussi haut sur une
bougie bénin
mais il aucun sont ils travaillaient sur
son corps s'était démené dans les mini
matches que j'ai vus à hiberner j'ai vu
un joueur physiquement techniquement et
des différents beaucoup plus agressif ou
plus explosif au panier
justement qui crée beaucoup plus de
décalage en live de son premier pas
oui la joie qui est différent je trouve
que la comparaison et jimmy brasseur
ambitieuse parce que je me batte
albigeois référés dans l'histoire de de
tout de tout le basket ball mais
mais oui c'est le joie différente
j'avais l'année dernière j'ai vraiment
j'ai vraiment hâte de le voir progresser
sa saison je crois qu'en termes de
tweets d'oeil les os et utile ça va être
à lui justement de développer des
nouveaux outils
comme on peut le voir
le travail
allen moi j'ai l'impression de la
dernière si je dis pas de bêtises une on
nous coupait c'était surtout un joueur
de catch and shoot qui crie pas
grand'chose match que pour lui ce qui va
changer ce qui peut faire changer de
catégorie de peindre la façon dont le
bois c'est justement cette capacité à
créer pour lui même un peu pour les
autres
[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on a nommé après franchement
je n'ai pas besoin de lui demander ça
pour prendre le pouvoir un traitement
voilà défend le défendre et 2 3 4 même
s'il est un peu petit pour les quatre
peut-être dans la nba y aura plus de
trains mais d'alignement où il sera
intéressant sur surface assez chaud n'a
pas besoin du ballon pour vivre bonne
mentalité
jeunes pour un vieux jeu ce qui n'est
pas vieux jeu pourra après points pour
un seigneur voilà il a hélas que 21 ans
et voit la progression chaque année pour
wii wii silas il ajoute des choses en
plus c'est bien mais je pense pas que
c'est ce qu'on lui demandera d'abord
pour voir le terrain en nba ce qu'on lui
demandera c'est de défendre coupe est
loin des ballons et m m ans potter et si
ça il montre qu'il peut le faire il il
faut une sélection au premier tour en
sans ambiguïté
vu que au chef fait tendance à l'accord
j'ai fait le consensus on va passer au
prochain arrêt avec des meilleurs
joueurs du championnat stoner pour les
autres
va passer ou prochain le rnb qu'asda
autre fait james nice m
je suis d'accord avec ça il combat au
club house oklahoma state
ouais alors pour le coup là on va sur un
sujet plus épineux
vrai de moussa cissé moussa cissé on
rappelle l'an dernier il arriva même
fils et le pivot peut-être le plus
attendu si on conserve pas de mots clés
comme un pivot mais scinder pivot le
plus attendu il est top 10 i/s piennes
donc c'est un monstre aquatique ça qu'il
faut dire d'avant tous écossais c'est
une bête quoi je vais te dire les
mensurations je les ai sous les yeux
devant aperam envergure c'est salif et
208 cm de haut de 21 dans leurs griffes
et 100 kg il a été un corps qui est
vraiment déjà très très très très
développé et les fluides dans toutes les
dimensions latéralement il peut vraiment
bougé sur des joueurs plus petits que
lui ils montrent très très haut le
problème c'est que s'il a encore fait
pour que le basket lem le basket landes
il a très peu de fondamentaux de jeu un
dernier joue pour penny hardaway
on sait que ça recruteurs incroyable
ancien joueur nba c'est une star on sait
qu'il a réussi envoyez des mecs à la
draft mais c'est pas forcément le en
tout cas mes yeux le plus grand
tacticien le le meilleur pour développer
ces jeunes a beaucoup de mecs qui quitte
ses programmes et on a vu ça avec vous
ça se dit c'est qui a fait une première
saison très compliqué beaucoup de fautes
de très mauvais placement peut toucher
etc il part à oklahoma state qui est
orphelin de quatre gammes dans une
équipe encore une fois il ya très très
peu de spinning donc c'est vraiment une
équipe de preuves physiques qui sont
plus fait pour faire du catch que pour
faire du basket et s'il ya des progrès
évidents notamment dans le placement sur
le positionnement des écrans etc on a
quand même un joueur qui pour l'instant
bourguiba qui brille pas
avec une équipe qui a plus on galère
dont va falloir voir dans le
développement
cndd son corps me suffit pour l'acheter
maintenant je sais pas quel point à
quelle place je l'achète pour l'instant
je vais plus est sur une jour du second
tour et pour moi c'est un joueur qui a
tout intérêt à être resté plusieurs
années pour confirmer ce corps en tant
que basketteur et avoir une vraie place
professionnels en tout cas tous les
outils physique soins
et de pivoine ancien alan
je sais pas j'ai une convention quand
les gens qui critiquent un peu quelques
nigam arrivera peut-être joué cette
année c'est est-ce que vous comprendrez
qu elle quelle situation ils étaient
dans la qualité est là
où ça si c'est ça c'est
à l'ancienne peut-être dans l'idée des
escales routes modernes dans l'idée du
rim rohner étaient présentés dans la
foule qui arrive de guinée il a fait
plusieurs lycées de mémoire aux états
unis
bénéficient pas je suis d'accord avec
hugues mulliez non en fait quand bennie
aussi dépendante des duvets du goire de
plaies qu'il a et on va pas se mentir
c'est un bon cru faire mais des fois il
a mal de certains profils et c'est pas
parce que tu es meneurs ou de marque et
prend une gare ne sont pas créé un bon
passeur et donc ça si c'est avec google
is ou
leicester qui cc je pense que rémy et
money beit déjà fait beaucoup de choses
pour lui sur le début d'année finisseur
d'action
menaces sur loeb
protecteur de cercle voilà prend des
fautes finit mal proche du panier parce
que les mains sont pas encore très bien
et les lectures sont pas très bonnes il
y as tout dit
le matériel on l'achète on leur vend le
j league ont le mot d'élise et on le
ramène régner c'est comme ça a très bien
fonctionné je pense des bonnes recettes
pour toi passagers league et après
oui oui je crois que je vois que il
risque même d'être un acteur de cette
année
riche même d'être dus à tête cette halle
6 présente là je crois qu'on est au
point je vois qu'il n'a pas un profil
complet du tout
oui je joue dans une équipe parce que
c'est pas évident pour lui d'avoir un
rôle très clair chaque ya rien qui est
très clair à otomo cette année mais
beaucoup de confusion sur le jeu
beaucoup de difficultés avec des
lectures du joueur mais mais le goal des
outils qu absolument établi et capable
de deux couples de
sport sur le terrain à une vitesse
complètement folle il est gros il est
fort il y ait quelque chose à faire là
lui justement mal en dise est dans le
moule bronner et ça c'est probable
le modèle l'archi type le plus simple à
un billet bâbord du succès elle tu mets
des écoles des côtes ce que ce que ton
monotone il fonce au panier puis dessus
des fonds selon nos besoins c'est tout
ce qu'on veut nullement les fermiers
même beaucoup beaucoup de travail en
france avec tout ça si c'est moche
apprend que si j'ai vraiment besoin d'un
pivot je peux assurer que j'achète pour
l'instant et on fait d'accord qui aime
beaucoup cette année deux ponts qui vaut
d'autres vont citer derrière moi et
cetera mais voilà on a une très grosse
cuve et de deux pivots besogneux donc je
pense que toutes les franchises pourquoi
lire
mark williams iii qui vous anime en
parle et adam mais voilà par exemple
mark williams mois sur l'autre ce match
est chouette cetera toutes les équipes
qui veulent avons été obligés de le lire
disons que c'est le meilleur pivot mais
voilà il va y avoir la viande pas cher
et donc non ça si c'est si l'appât des
échos le premier temps je sais même pas
s'il va y aller peut-être qu'il va
racheter plein 6 et comme à scotty louis
ça peut le faire avant lui mais ce
serait pas forcément une bonne chose
pour lui
qui est ce que tu as encore de sedan une
conférence en un mois ce listing aya
bien plein plein de joueurs milla jalan
richie ce qu'ils essaient de devenir
mickeal british à west virginia à
surveiller malgré un genou qui me gêne
notre au point donc à surveiller côté b
lors parce que c'est quand même les
champions en titre effectivement cannes
valbonne mais qui est freshman je vais
me laisser du temps
le polonais alors je sais pas car et
milton voilà moi je dis social de six
mille dix mâts comme ça te dis donc je
préfère ne pas le dire pour lui de
froisser nos amis tu me vois une maman
et sa en allemagne
on abat pareil si tu veux de la viande
casher kansas david mc cormack qui vaut
avec 10 et pour le plus large que mon
corps en longueur
terre henson junior texas tech là il ya
pire qu'une demande et texas tech moi
j'ai pas regardé encore texas tech cette
année malgré notre frenchie daniel bacio
après voilà beaucoup beaucoup de joueurs
mac mal et pis si tu veux du enfin pour
jouer en europe beaucoup de profils que
encore une confiance qui régale stan et
ça marche on enchaîne sur la big east je
sais pas si c'est un régal dans mini van
bommel
moi je suis très content de l'avoir
récupéré parce que regardent de basket
et mieux je me porte que l'api qui
c'était une conférence pour expliquer un
peu aux gens qui on voit pas autant de
prospects une écoute ou du moins pas
autant de winnenden c'est une prospects
façades et des programmes très très long
qui ont une très forte réputation etc et
on peut commencer avec le premier
peut-être le meilleur prospect que je
vais présenter des tests pour vous
donner des noms de l'équipe de big
yukon creighton de paul marquet
providence saint john's est un homme
voilà donc que des programmes vous avez
plusieurs jours référence est maintenant
nba la providence a envoyé du connacht
voyez le james bond technopolitaine a
envoyé des villes duke donc voilà c'est
que des noms qu'on retrouve son et
notamment villanova est le programme
phare de cette conférence et qu'est ce
que je vais commencer par les prospects
de villanova 6 à 9 ans oui
on parle du coup sur tarn ain samuel
hahnemann samuel c'est un ailier ailier
fort de petite taille qui joua à nova
cette année les en quatrième année c'est
un mec qui bride à croire son tir à
trois points la nba va de sa clé
d'entrée pour la nba ça un joueur de
gros volumes et très efficace et bon
défensivement
athlétiquement très limité dans le corps
une fois dans les déplacements axe
panier panier latéralement je trouve
assez lent mais très puissant c'est un
joueur qui a développé du skill cette
balle en main maintenant on est capable
de se créer son propre tir pour le
niveau une sieste est pas ce que je vais
lui demander paul nba mais ça reste
toujours très intéressant c'est un bon
passeur il est formé par jay white donc
forcément il ya du qi basket donc voilà
c'est peut-être le deuxième meilleur
prospect de ça le moteur de sa fac avec
justin lourd il se tire un peu la bourre
haut niveau tu es au niveau de mam au
niveau de mon coeur mais voilà c'est un
prospect très intéressant qui peut pour
du soulier dieu partir au second tour
sans trouble
parce que j'ai l'impression que tout est
propre et de nova ça ressemble un peu la
présente à chaque fois les mêmes
objectifs sérieux des joueurs
intelligents on sait déjà c'est des
joueurs pas très grand mais voilà qui
sont plus bas
sur samuel ouais ouais
cache ta joie c'est parce que
[Musique]
justin morrow collègue
philippe c est moi cette future backup
moder et demi et je pense à peu ça peut
faire justin mort très bon tireur uglas
diermen samuel c'est un super senior en
plus c'est sa cinquième année donc voilà
il a l'expérience et il ya plus a plus
de vécu plus de deux que tous les
joueurs qu'ils affrontent donc ça valait
des
tirs à trois points c'est un peu nouveau
de mémoire 44 un nom ouais c'est ça de
mémoire la mécanique n'était pas
exceptionnel et les volumes tenter non
plus et en progressant que ça s'améliore
voilà il arrive voiture ça peut
intéresser des équipes mais ce sera un
jour des prêches basketball comme tu
l'avais dit puis retracement des listes
jointes milano voir un jour de rotation
qui ont fait trois quatre ans nous conte
sur les fondamentaux qui savent faire
une ou deux choses bien et qui fera
d'eux qu'ils font rien d'une méga
négatif et bien sûr gars réalistes ils
restent tous la nba donc josh art brych
is
17 mp au sadique des quantités chronique
eric pascal arty diacono di vincenzo
voilà donc ces gens là ils vont une
place ont peut-être un big
ben est ce que tu l'as vu à vilanova
oui ou villa nova tunes et quelques
jeunes femmes regard des cinq zones
urbaines c'est un gars qui est très bon
au contact qui a peur du contact qui
fonce au panier s'il faut
que j'appelle un pq repos et zone type
de joie ça dit que s'ils suscitent
robert défensive votre 63.6 tu es trop
attaquer attaquer ton clausade puis
partout au panier puis j'ai essayé de
défoncer à peu près le monde ses ports
le joueur le plus sophistiqué mais c'est
un joueur qui joue selon ces forces qui
joue à l'état de lui même ce qui est une
grosse marque joueurs de villanova et
que le dialogue
joue en tant que super senior à nos voix
comme avec les schémas respect
discipline peu jourdain 7e 8e en nba
donc je pense que le profil est assez
clair et se regardent nommé car est très
très haut rhône qui équivaut souvent
s'est passé ce sont plus de mise en
avant villanova les deux derniers
arrêtent à couiner reliques arrive avec
une brosse à épi transfert est amour et
un antoine contenant on entend plus
parler c'est un excellent joueur bronson
c'est différent c'est de l'amour de
l'histoire de nova mais il est resté
deux ans donc c'est des gens qui sont
dans un moule donc je pense que c'est ce
qu'il faut retenir
comme enchaîne avec le prochain ouais
donc avec plaisir alors on va partir sur
julian chang panique de champagny
normalement le nous non connaît il ya un
confrère qui maintenant je pense et tang
raptors ouais voilà ferme de 10 avions
un truc alors que les jours se
ressemblent un petit peu un du vin de
champagne et du coup ça jones dont qui
joua à new york il est junior cette
année c'est un ailier alors il va jouer
ailier fort wayne billet un peu comme
matthew meilleur c'est un mec qui pas
très athlétique qui va dominer au niveau
n 6 est parce qu il sait marquer de
partout il peut te postée il peut tirer
à trois points il pleut pas mi distance
c'est un très fort rebondeur c'est un
bon passeur pour le poste donc voilà ça
mec polyvalent qui marque de partout
latéralement c'est difficile pour lui
donc c'est pareil ça que tu vas caché
sur le mois sur le moins bons ailiers
adverses porteur de balle maintenant
elle a fait des progrès dans le clip
basket collectif ça c'est toujours
important pour moi des deux côtés je lui
ai dit c'est un gars nsamé qui 32 dents
mentalité new yorkaise donc voilà c'est
même style que matthew meilleur tu peux
essayer d'avoir une équipe qui va mais
prêt vais essayer d'aller chercher ce
mec là est en nba tu demanderas vraiment
de catch and shoot catch and shoot
katchou été puis sur un renversement de
faire le le bon play
va très bien se profile entre 20 30
qui lui sur un joueur qui met kim et des
paniers qui partant du ballon pour vivre
du spot 3,4 sur un jeune jaime pagny et
je regrette pas il est bien meilleur que
son frère pour moi y'a aucun aucun débat
est bien bien meilleur que j'estime
qu'elle s'offre à szczecin rivoire qui
joue à pitre mais c'est pas mauvais
d'ailleurs qu'un tout est né rapporte et
tulasne champagne pour moi c'est un
accord de rotation des
bennes voies de saint john ukhov way we
feel quand même plutôt simple quand je
te tuer dix joueurs et c'est un joueur
intelligent ce que j'aime beaucoup je
vois rude en défense ce que j'aime
beaucoup évoqué la les fois où est ce
que je les ai vus se passe je vois que
le plus car t il il va créer vraiment dû
des situations crise si on sait ce que
j'aime vraiment beaucoup peut-être pour
la vision la plus
l'année croyable mais joue à l'intérieur
de ces mais joue à l'intérieur de ces
mots et j'espère aussi
gras voire exact moi j'avais 2
2 m 01 100 kg
2 m 01 ça je le voyais flêtre plus
poisseux crois que costa 4 mais oui
comme le dylan c'est un jour
il est assez clair très bien ce qui
pourrait à nîmes bader
je réponds juste un momentum production
là qui demande si on a parlé des
prospects internationaux en fait on fait
un tour d el mejjad donc on parle des
prospects vois pas d'où ils viennent des
meilleurs programmes est rien
[Musique]
on enchaîne son ton dernier prospects
ouais alors je les prie pour faire
plaisir à la non cadrée richmond donc
anciens de cluj moi j'ai décidé de pas
être beaucoup de new yorkais aujourd'hui
qui qui maintenant jouer à cet homme
paul donc j'ai par watt un rayon d'une
liste qui sont orphelins de de lordat
centre omaoc la dgi dit le géorgien
cadres et richmond ça avant tout un
profil de défenseur incroyable d'une
bête sur l'homme cedh et bras
interminables capable de tenir quasiment
tous les tous les profils de jeu est un
peu long post 4 c'est un agresseur c'est
un tir à ne manquer pas là qu'il essaie
de développer pour pouvoir espérer vivre
en nba et qu'on va attendre là c'est un
début de saison très compliqué pour
l'instant on va être honnête mais il ya
que trois petits matches dont une
exposition médiatique
par contre au michigan où il a mis 0
point en tout cas hélas il a marqué zéro
panier donc c'était très difficile mais
ce serait manquer de respect de ne pas
souligner son travail défensif sur les
sur les gars de michigan qui scanne
caisse quand même des prospects
professionnels de très très très haut
niveau donc voilà khaddari richmond
avant tout accord une longueur de bras
si tu sim et des tirs à trois points on
va l'envisager très haut dans la draft
team pas de tir à trois points ça peut
être très compliqué pour lui
halal vu que je sais que c'est un petit
peu un de tes chouchous deal nous que
nous pauvres molle dure ne voit pas
c'est une très bonne question c'est
quand j'ai mis jamais des clips de lui à
un mois et je les envoyais aller à des
amis à moi qui bosse pas sûr de la nsia
mais qui sont full nba je leur ai dit
est ce que dans la caisse que vous voyez
ce qu'en fait je vois un joueur camp
genevois se déplacer sur le terrain et
l'envié en fait moi je sois jouault
giannino bien je vois comment il est et
place la longueur les la manière dont il
a de ceux des pastèques le ballon je
vois de jaude janabi je dis pas que ça
de niro et jane hobby
qui progresse énormément mais
il a tout du profil je pense qu'il peut
être je pense que c'est sur les bases
extérieur le prospect
meilleur niveau défensif actuellement il
peut créer
problème c'est qu'il a gris-bleu moyens
et que le dire est une question qu'une
mécanique équipe qui est un peu bizarre
et jean-marie ce kyste ans un peu mais
le corps est intéressant c'est un joueur
pro team toi et ta rapt et je pense au
premier tour pour pas mal de ses
attributs même s'il qui revient pas
pense que dit il les tire lui apprendra
en nba s'il n'apprend pas si tu as le
hs d'accord dixon
benno est ce qu'on y croit au
développement du tir un gros défenseur
même si lui même s'était tiré pas de
rodez france sera le gros lot d'un
défenseur intelligent
je parle dans un article qui pas encore
si du comment aller à la statue avec les
vols de balle mais lui c'est un luxe non
seulement comme envoie le ballon mais
c'est qu'en valais baron aussi les très
très intelligent dans les ligues bros
moi je dis regardez là les nerfs à cause
de quincy guéri
je suivais mon beau et quincy guéri à
ses acquis aux puis je suis grand combat
en un mot avec darwich mène très bon
pour est accompagné aussi
rapide explosif il ya sûrement qui
paient la leçon pour attaquer pagny
fonctionne très bien
oui dribbler pour support le tir est pas
là pour l'instant mais comme comme 18 a
lancé c'est vraiment le profil avec
laquelle travaille et je comprends
pourquoi j'ai quitté ses lacs use je
suis très très très excité de le voir
dans un nouveau contexte parce que je
crois que c'est un joueur qui est
absolument tous les outils pour être
drafté hôpitaux
est en négatif qui joue que 22 minutes
passaient aussi bright fall kane qui est
un des meilleurs meneurs qui est bien
d'art voir des trucs c'est grâce à harry
caine qui closent de mode contenus
notamment ben y'a pas que l'équipe ans
et à noël il ya paul qui pose une bonne
question meilleurs défenseurs exter de
la cuvée pour vous on agit pour moi ça
veut dire
qu'on t'a rien pour que je te pauthe
entré le défendre à moi tu me dis
l'extérieur je prends des buts par le
dépôt petit est pour moi une pâte qui
bouge tellement trop bien et a plus
d'expérience qui a joué plus de gros
moments plus de deux meilleurs joueurs
donc je partirai sur lui mais y'a plein
de pur défenseur extérieur tu vois total
une flanigan on est sisi à aubenas qui
joue pas à mes carnets dans ce sera
incroyable extérieur
d'une surdose tout à l'heure mais ses
cadres mais c'est khaddari paul c'est
pas mal
a raconté ses cadets
qu'est-ce qu'il ya encore un énorme
attention à ce que tu dis là j'ai
préparé une petite liste aussi moi parce
que j'adore j'adore la biguine
hobby mutual qui d'autre sur ta bosse
liste bon après en gros gégé villanova
via nova villa nova était la nova non
mais là justin moore madonna palette
alors qui est qui peut vraiment enfoncé
c'est un bout ligue 1 il prend la balle
les longs mythes ont quitté crasy mais
d'être au point coline dit lipsky qui
s'est blessé l'an dernier match mendes
qui a un meneur de jeu hyper expérimenté
jeu voir post pas aussi quitte écrasé
non j'aime beaucoup
aller pour changer un peu ne va andré
jackson yukon ce feu mort athlète
incroyable aussi donc je vais attendre
un petit peu du cône d'en voir un peu
plus pour pour kiffer je pense que la
brea noah ni le vase estime mme scruggs
[Musique]
venir de derrière c'est ça oui super
senior et je pense que peut être qu'au
premier tour
ce moment des meilleurs joueurs du scion
doren
catimini aux qualités très
rapidement à l'aise aviaire sa fille et
prom de l'ohio
et post-crise
il va avoir bientôt 24 ans il est à plus
de 100 matches ont ils expliqué il sait
tout bien faire et cette année il est
porteur de valdo xavier
je compare pas j'avais dit dans cette
vidéo du g10 je ne compare pas les des
lieux je compare pas à des semaines
benoît plus dureté mais s'il ya un
joueur qui peut dans un moule de
l'extérieur 22 23 ans avec un rôle bien
précis qui n'est pas négatif pour une
équipe je pense que ça peut être
proscrite donc voila et j'ai trouvé
extrêmement bon j'ai dans le match
contre aurillac et c'est le seul match
que vous aviez vu pour l'instant tu me
plais vraiment vraiment bonne donc voilà
paul scrubs à norcross runs et puis
sinon pour faire plaisir à m olivier
maxence prospère marque est
belle est ce que les québécois
d'histoire de moi je connais ça tu
attends voilà justement je suis ici
je suis une ministre wen non mais son
nom m'échappe de manager à minima
je
laime
ripoche en extraire les trois soirées
raclette oui rochon alexandrie le
sundance aussi
obligés de nous sommes bien ouais rien
arthur kaloum a jugé souviens d'en
parler oui john legend et mohamed très
demandé que j'ai déjà choisi la nova
étaient trois dans la raquette
et aminu
cette forme corporelle
le petit frère 1 et mordre sur tellement
très tôt on doit les traiter pour je
n'étais pas doué
c'est pour l'europe
pacal ou mentalement il est très
convaincante lehmann démarré mardi
il fait quoi et 5 10 ça bouge mais vous
voyez les tout petits et tout petits
[Musique]
on voit la tour merci on va passer
la main à steve
appel il reste deux conférences qu'on va
faire on va cueillir style tout de suite
pour ça ça lui steve salut les gars et
forcément ça comment ça va pas bien je
m'entendais la terre je crois que je
viens points c'est vrai c'est vrai
j'aime beaucoup la barre bleue très
glorieux
mais recèle effectivement
steve kean autre spécialiste de l'e 6 6
qui va nous présenter dans trois jours
je te laisse commencer par celui que tu
veux vas-y jeu technique on va commencer
par cas les blogs voilà dos carolina
sophomore un meneur meilleurs combos qui
fait un mètre 93 pour 2 m
19,1 voilà donc ça déjà première confort
élément intéressant chez lui ce qu'il a
des très longs bras les sorties d'une
saison en fin d'une période de high
school où il était placé cinq étoiles
grosse recrue à north carolina il n'a
pas fait une très très bonne saison
l'année dernière à mahut difficultés
mais il n'a pas été aidé non plus par le
contexte collectif voilà donc le profil
de joueur c'est un honneur plutôt
scoreur plutôt slasher il tire beaucoup
mais on va revenir c'est pas encore sont
souvent fort loin de là il est très bon
dans drive sur la transition et à north
carolina l'année dernière on avait une
équipe avec rapid spanning voilà ça joue
avec deux grands de gros big men donc
belle cote
charles keszler c'est des mecs qui font
2,6 2,7 qui sont très costauds ils
prenaient la raquette avec tout le
l'organisation offensive de l'équipe de
williams et s est donné un bal au grand
les grands souvenez se poser post le bas
est donc pour lui avait pas de couloir
de 1 contre un c'est très difficile de
driver donc il était vraiment vraiment
pas mis en valeur et ça c'est un
problème récurrent dans ce cas là depuis
quelques années voilà on a eu la
jurisprudence avec avec l'année dernière
qu'ual anthony même il ya deux ans kobe
white c'était la même chose c'est des
gars qui avaient du mal an et du mal ans
en collège et dès qu'il soit arrivé en
nba tout de suite plus d espace voilà
ils ont pu jouer en 1 contre 1 avr alors
là il met des points tout simplement
quoi et faire ce qu'ils savaient faire
dans des conditions qui étaient plus
optimales pour eux voilà donc sur les
pour sa saison plus précisément et là il
a fini à onze points par match voilà
c'est pas beaucoup par rapport aux
vraiment il faut comprendre qu'il
arrivait vraiment avec voilà cinq
étoiles avec tout le profil des peuples
ailleurs avec des pourcentages très
vilain il a à 34% à 2 voilà très faible
et 26% 26% à 3 points voilà il prend peu
près cinq tirs 5 tirs par match à trois
points peut-être un peu moins 20 soit un
volume assez important don qui tient
beaucoup mais pour l'instant ils tirent
pas très bien dans la mécanique moi je
suis vraiment pas convaincu et
l'impression qu'ils changent de tir en
fait certaines situations il a pas la
même gestuelle il est très régulier il
est capable de mettre une ficelle puis
sur le tir d'après une planche donc là
c'est en tirez pas encore fixée voilà
c'est un vrai travail qui doit faire on
soit en tout cas sur le volume qu'il a
que l'année dernière il avait quand même
étiquette que le sont tout le staff
l'encourager à tirer parce que quand tu
tiendras avec des pourcentages aussi
faible que tu continues toute la saison
a attiré 5 6 fois par match c'est que
derrière je pense que le staff on
t'encourage à faire ça
mais voilà en tout cas on sent qu'il ya
une envie de travailler là dessus qu'ils
allaient tickets shoots mais que pour
l'instant ça rentre pas et qu'un travail
technique à faire là-dessus sans
violence effroyable sur 70 pourtant donc
rien de catastrophique mais on sent que
c'est vraiment un axe de travail très
important c'est lui
dans les points forts il a bat déjà son
gabarit son physique il est frêle mais
il bouge bien il descend bas il va vite
donc il est hyper intéressant en
transition et qu'il faut pousser la
balle il est très très bon sur ça il a
aussi des outils pour défendre voilà il
le fait plutôt bien sûr porter et non
porteur il a fait pas mal interceptions
parce que autant la taxe north carolina
mais vraiment pas terrible l'année
dernière autant ce qui est proposé en
défense étaient beaucoup plus
intéressant avec des défenses agressé sa
défense et aux élus effectivement que
les bracci là s'ils m'appellent
intensité il arrivait vraiment être sur
les lignes de passes il gratté pas mal
de ballons là dessus en défense porter
il est intéressant aussi quand il est
vraiment concentré il est vraiment
capable d'être très très fort en défense
et ça c'est vraiment un élément sur
lequel il va pouvoir s'appuyer pour être
drafté je pense que dans une ville où il
ya beaucoup de boîtes qui sont très très
forts les équipes tourne vraiment autour
des initiateurs avoir un gars qui est
capable de défendre sur des 1 2 et là
vraiment les bras pour être capable de
prendre soin des gains peu plus grand
que lui et hyper intéressant donc je
pense que ça c'est un aspect sur lequel
voilà les gm ont plutôt apprécié et
sur le sur le drive il a une capacité
comme elle se faufiler à driver avec des
changements demain et changements de
direction et changements de rythme et ce
que j'aime beaucoup dans ses capacités à
driver c'est que en dépit d'un physique
relativement frêle un gars qui va
beaucoup contact il est bien aimé
l'épaule il n'a pas de succès à se
situer en l'air et chose qui fait mais
qui fait vraiment très très bien
voilà sur juste un petit mot va sur le
début de saison m6 échantillons et super
faible c'est hyper encourageant tout ce
qui est ce qui a commencé à montrer les
pourcentages sont en hausse ça soit à
deux points à 3 points mais
considérablement mais si l'échantillon
encore une fois est très faible c'est
une consigne qui perd beaucoup de
ballons parce que c'est un aspect sur
lequel est de travailler sur pelé
menking il a manqué d'assurance parfois
ont senti qu'ils savaient pas trop
mettre la balle et il perdait pas mal de
ballons c'est pas un excellent passeur
et un garçon qui est capable de faire
bouger la balle bien sûr mais ce n'est
pas une grosse grosse force de création
et même sur les tournois elle est pas
mal à dernière là il est en train d'en
perdre beaucoup moins et puis va plus
souvent sur la ligne aussi l'année
dernière il avait pas énormément sur la
ligne parce que quand tu mets deux gars
des deux sets de 8,2 10 dans la raquette
trouver des drive c'est compliqué là il
a plus de place pour plus de fautes pour
voir si ça continue sur la saison mais
en tout cas à suivre est assez
encourageant voilà
à l'aide je sais que des annotations
vallée dit le plus grand bien de calais
blob l'année dernière est ce que tu
valides le foie de thé tout
ça parce qu'il vient de saint louis oui
mais ça
m
je suis d'accord avec tout ce qu'a dit
si moi je suis père encourager pour ses
premiers mois tu en fait surtout moi je
n'ai vu qu'un seul en entier suit ces
suis sûr je suis contre charleston et en
fait j'ai pas vu le même jour que j'ai
bien un jour quitter j'ai vu le joueur
convoyant high school en fait beaucoup
plus en confiance son passeur prescrit
sortir aller il fait plus de passes des
jets moins de pertes de balles les
moeurs pourcentage c'est bien qu'il soit
resté en toilettes j'en aurais pu se
dire maintenant je m'en vais et mais en
même temps il est aisé parce que bas il
ya deux semaines quartier à droite du
matin qui sont arrivées respectives
nouveau coach carwin walton qu'un des
meilleurs shooteurs rebelles s'y est
pour moi la meilleure bien meilleur
environnement
ben on achète jusqu'à quel point qui
avec les bleus pour mon pays
bright comme le disait si bien si vous
moi c'est vraiment le sol et je suis
vraiment afin de batailler contre le
chik
vous faire histoires courtes à ses
chiens adorables mais il est absolument
incapable de m'en parler un zoom il
devient complètement fou de jalousie
même
s'il était laissé un mois de galas bloc
j'achète pas beaucoup trop
il a cette
façon dont il tombe dans son style
toujours hors des kills et moi ça me
m'agace beaucoup je vois pas ce que
c'est quelque chose qui commence est
difficile à corriger
le hot vers la mécanique du haut du
corps et par ex et leap x ouvrir un
oui il son corps je suis un autre joueur
que son convoi langer durant l'été coup
plus agressif beaucoup plus explose un
autre joie que j'ai vus par des valeurs
le match aller avec son billet pas
réussi et fait tomber des gars au
périmètre
est ce que
est ce que le le passing le le le
le talent de passeur pour être capable
justement d'une fan de rendre son
problème de tir un peu moins important
je sais pas je pense qu'on soit
convaincu de calais blog je vais à vous
et avec vous je suis mieux mais
est ce qu'on n'est pas un peu sur le
fichier du combo guard on sait pas trop
où m on sait pas trop où mettre un ni
deux ni par moi seul rappeur c'est banal
et
ouais un petit peu sur la toile après
qu'elle eût connu
peut-être peut-être mais ça jarque avait
été après la balle en main par produit
ne connais pas trop où le hezbollah a
taquiné connais pas trop donc pour
s'attacher au kiné faut qu'il soit
meilleur ans potable
ça s'arrête et pas sûr qu'ils aient
beaucoup de stations soit parce que
l'emplacement sur l'attaqué fait pour
qu'il crée pas mal qu'on voit ici
steam on passe au prochain un pivot de
luxe c'est çà çà çà à mark williams
donc 1,7 pied il est à l écran de 13 de
ouais très grand donc plus pareil beau
parcours à henri school
son point fort tout de suite dès qu'on
voit jouer ces ballons dépit de sa
taille bouge bien voilà il bouge très
bien même je trouve pour à ses pieds
vraiment ils hypermobiles pas très
costaud du haut du corps mais contre sa
cavale et donc barre par l envergure est
immense enjeu de 25 voilà un
très grand très mobile très longue
forcément déjà à toutes les protections
cercle ses élites en c1 il est parfois
difficile à est attaqué le cerf quand il
est là quand il est sur les aides que tu
es faible paraît il à la mobilité la
capacité à prendre les impôts ou arrivé
au bon moment donc c'est très très
compliqué à attaquer quand il est là
c'est vraiment pas déjà là dessus
facilement transposable sur 1 sur les
billets ya même pas de souci on sait que
lui il va faire ça très très bien
n'diaye pas ce que vous en pensez mais
moi je vois pas pourquoi il serait
incapable de le faire à l'échelon et hop
splice capacités physiques pour le pour
le faire là dessus c'est vraiment
vraiment très très bien il ya une saison
très particulière et dernière sauf que
début de saison il jouait pas du tout
donc je peux il était sûr sur 5 15
minutes et puis à partir de février mars
il signa ait start et a joué énormément
3 15 et 30 minutes parce que quand
johnson est partie john johnston et ça
libère une place sur les bosquette 5 et
là il a vraiment été excellent donc tu
vas vraiment dans ce registre là
excellent rebondeur of aussi parce que
il est quand même si on prend la stat
avancé il à 20% 15% de rebond of ce qu
est ce qui est vraiment très très bien
ce qui est dans les meilleures ici si
ensuite en attaque bas il a pas grand
chose 1 c'est de prendre les positions
il a pas souvent les ballons il a sept
points par match année dernière mais
c'est essentiellement sur dur en bourse
qui remonte sur la transition
éventuellement ou sur durolle pour les
écrans il les dépose pas hyper bien à
peut-être parce qu'il est pas
suffisamment costaud mais je trouve que
sur les écrans il est passé un pacte en
effet pas de rêver qu'à l'ajout du pick
and roll il aime bien slip et les écrans
est parce qu il bouge bien aussi elle
possède pas ce qu'on lui demande moi je
trouve qu'il fait un peu trop en tout
cas ils aiment bien dd qui va affronter
au pic dès qu'ils voient ils voient que
ça colle s'astique il aime bien les
repartir sur le backdoor tout ça sur des
coupes mais en attaque c'est vrai que
c'est pas c'est pas un garçon qui va qui
va énormément ce corps et je pense pas
que ça soit son registre le foot
est
vraiment pas à pas ça il a à 50 % aux
lancers francs voilà donc
bon c'est vrai joueur sera capable de
s'écarter avec le tir on serait
compliqué donc pareil ça sera pas sans
registre
par contre voilà potentiellement trop
gros défenseur capable protéger le
cercle et sur le dernier match que j'ai
vu aujourd'hui j'ai revu le match contre
le mot ville dernier match de la saison
il a dit ça sous deux chefs ça soude
chez decca et pick and roll notamment
sur carrick jones et défendre sur
carrick jones qui était quand même un
des meilleurs meneurs ici c'est une
dernière et je crois une fois seulement
qu'ahidjo à ce que si avoir lancé mais
sinon je pars du temps où il jouait même
pas y lâcher la balle et une ou deux
fois il ya été n'a paru si donc
peut-être qu'on a 1 5 qui capable de
fait qu'un petit peu c'est la grande
question sur son mark williams je crois
que j'ai à peu près tout dit ce que
j'avais envie de dire oui parfois il
manque un peu de sûreté je trouve voilà
je trouve que je suis un peu bougé
parfois et liquidèrent il manque un peu
de surprises et de muscles peut être
inquiet et sinon c'est voilà c'est un
joueur c'est ce qu'il va faire et je
pense qu'il fera plutôt bien à l'échelon
supérieur
alain est ce que c'est un profil de
riner que tu aimes bien prono début de
second tour est-ce que c'est lui mais
c'est le prochain de la liste daniel
graf michelle robinson robert williams
c'est ce genre de jour là qu'il faut
qu'on parte pas mais l'idée c'est ça
prendre développe sublime a raison il ya
peu il ya pas mal de qui on va le voir
jouer on va dire que c'est pas faire
grand chose en attaque ouais mais en
fait il va si l'on dit c'est très bien
faire d'autres choses et qu'on est noirs
de les répéter plein de fois qu'il est
fait à un niveau moyen aux moyens plus
ou très bien
c'est le poste simple en billets ces
deux postures ce qu'on demande le monde
est plus simple la nba et moi collins
est plus que capable de se relever comme
le disait cif moi ce qui me fait
vraiment flipper avec mark williams sa
mobilité dans les petits rôles c'est sa
capacité à changer de direction flow
terrain le gars qui le groupe français
renault pas se permettre bookmarks ne
suis qu'un joueur accepte pro charles
est capable de bouger aussi rapidement
sa chambre de la géométrie d'un match
beaucoup plus difficile dans lequel
cercle c'est beaucoup plus facile pour
les pour les autres équipes de pro du
poker pour lequel il jouait défendre oui
steig bien parler des mesures t du
problème des écrans mais mark williams
selon moi depuis les ports de
jackson conson johnson up montrer les
qualités
qui vous titulaire en bis je vois
le jackson
dix soirées une bille est capable de
défendre cercle il va être
éventuellement capables de des écrins il
explose et fils et l'on y met chien
selon les proches du cercle
faut avoir un impact gabba gabba
propose qu'on a fait tout parce
qu'effectivement comme tu l'as dit ben
c'est un profil assez simple et koné ce
jour 2 de deux joueurs on va passer on
en parle depuis des années illzach te
ment on va passer hakem al oumouma de
vtech virginia tech c'est bien ça ouais
ça là on a un choix un peu plus âgés 198
c1 seniors
sa deuxième année à virginia tech donc
l'année dernière il a été c'était le
meilleur joueur de son équipe clairement
nous attaquerons peu pour lui bien
meilleur taux usage meilleur scoring
meilleur rebondeur
s'est il fait 2 6 2 6 2 11 12 ouvertures
il est
relativement mobile manque un peu
d'explosivité il est pas hyper comment
dire il perd 7 physiquement un garçon
car un peu de voilà un peu grassouillet
un petit peu un travail à faire de ce
point de vue là je pense en salle de
muscu impose ifad qui au-delà de 5% je
pense mais c'est un garçon d'un vague
dance de 12 mois j'ai
ouais c'est pas très long mais c'est pas
non plus voilà ce correct tout à fait
mais en attaque il a
aujourd'hui il est capable de scorer sur
du poste bas voilà vraiment dos au
panier en fait sauf à mi distance celle
à qui un peu plus utilisé voilà sur du
travail sur du corn soda du mi distance
récupère est bas il fait un arrêt à
effacer puis joue sur un contre un et on
commence à essayer de tirer un petit peu
à trois points voilà faut savoir sur ces
deux premières années quand il n'était
pas qu'on n'était pas à virginia tech il
avait pris aucun tir à vos forces aucun
tir en deux saisons
donc là il a commencé un peu à tirs à
trois points on n'est pas encore sûr
voilà sur un excellent tir à trois
points mais il arrive à en mettre un
petit peu
fait combien l'année dernière mais
300 à 3 pour leur dérober voilà 35 % à
2,6 oui
c'est pas mal du tout c'est encourageant
c'est encourageant voilà pour une
première saison il se met à tirer c'est
pas mal du tout et et en défense il est
il est intéressant il protège un peu le
certes mais ça sera pas demain que sa
principale qualité c'est un bon rôdeur
voilà il est sympa sur fonctionnelle est
capable de bouger la balle il va pas
casser le rythme des attaques sur des
défenses de zone il joue au poste euros
il est tout à fait capable je vais sur
de la lots par exemple lors des accents
la passe 11 jours passent à terre un
élan créateur mais voilà c'est un garçon
qui est capable de passer la balle dans
de bonnes conditions et
puis oui voilà ce sera ta son c'est un
joueur qui est assez âgé ça sera des
meilleurs joueurs ici si c'est un des
mois j'en fais mon favori
personnellement pour être le meilleur
joueur de la conférence par contre
question du question du plafond voilà je
rage et ils seraient incapables de
progresser d'avoir une vraie carrière
nba je sais pas est-ce que ça c'est un
profil vraiment une bille dans ce que
j'en n'ai coup c'est un peu la
dérogation qui veut que j'ai c'est un
poste a qu'à taper à l'ancienne je
trouve alaia à côté un peu post 4 d'il
ya 10 15 ans tu as du mal à passer carte
est effectivement je pense moi que
l'enjeu pour lui s'il valait 1 de
billets c'est le tir extérieur s'est dit
capable d'écarter le jeu
là peut-être qu'ils pourraient ils
pourraient faire un peu de nba mais
sinon effectivement c'est pas le poste 4
plus recherché un billet j'ai le
sentiment koala
haleine comme on le projette je connais
très peu très honnêtement je veux pas
trop en parler parce que
je regarde passer gergy noter que je
devrais je devrais regarder le nom même
agréable à regarder aplatir ça joue bien
ouais tu vas près se regarder
je regarderai plus on va mettre constat
n'est pas ce que j'avais deux cousines
répondu steam
je sais pas je sais pas si tu as regardé
beaucoup notre aide à mon travail j'en
ai mais tactiquement parlant la façon
dont il me rappelle un peu de bonne
direction
je vous dis que lyon à strasbourg oui
voila je voyais que ça pourquoi pas oui
oui qui est un peu juste à qui attaquent
au poste bas qui met beaucoup dit très
physique qui m'écoutent pression sur le
panier ouais ouais justement acquis cap
de foire le tout rappelle bansi cause je
crois que tu l'a nommé trouve un joueur
qui mérite non pas de lui un joueur qui
roule sa bosse qui traîne son équipe sur
ses épaules je ne crois pas que ce soit
comme celle nba mais on sait jamais
c'est vraiment s'il pleut développés
sont à trois points il ya déjà une belle
efficacité ajoute cette année pour 55 %
ce qui est quand même assez énorme
pourquoi pas moi je me dis pourquoi pas
il shoote pas beaucoup en mes temps qui
va se mettre à tirer sur la gâchette pas
être peut-être mais où c'est un
changement qui très très agréable à
regarder jouer je trouve un bon dans le
blue sea de james ellroy à villanova
homme avec un peu plus de
responsabilités sur les
sivom en finir avec woods schiste dans
ta conférence qui on regarde qui tuent
nous conseille de regarder et pourquoi
moi je vais commencer par les les
freshmen des yeux que quand même et
bonbons queiroz n'a pas besoin je pense
de moi pour regarder mais bong héros
voilà parce que parce que ça bouge bien
parce que c'est très porteur qu'un super
haendel pour un joueur de sa taille
qui voir voir s'il va être capable de
jouer dans un bon système plus collectif
moi c'est ça que ma banque qui reçoit
que je veux voir sur la compréhension
des systèmes de jeu depuis basket c'est
le shoot meeting sur ces aspects là on
va s'arrêter quand même deux autres
héros parce que c'est quand même un des
top tic 2 les prochaines on est d'accord
avec ça haleine puisque ton on a vu toi
pour l'instant
t
il il ya impressionnant
le rapport le rapport qualité balle en
main ce qu'il cède pour sa taille son
poids c'est pas normal en fait c'est
juste qu'ils sont pas normales mais ils
sont plus en plus visible chez les îles
et les joueurs modernes donc voir
comment il va être utilisé avec beaucoup
demi de règne sur le premier match on a
vu on a vu moins initiés de l'attak
alors que c'était ce qu'ils aient un peu
au lycée donc voir voir comment ça va se
passer pour lui dans ce pays n'est pas
toujours optimale à duke mais elle est
extrêmement froid
ils viennent puisque qu'est ce que tu as
vu j'étais marquée par les fonds seront
également de très bons c'est oui willy
métriques non plus comme tous ces
supports aspect qu'on les voit
au
[Musique]
collège un peu comme au lycée est
capable de tout et derrière ils sont
séduits c'est un
pur quels sont les laisse de par
l'obliqué rouge jusqu'à maintenant aller
dans les grosses confrontations
non je vous conseille de vous égarer
bientôt la wac juggles à gaza je vais
regarder ça sur la t4 mais je passe
formation qui va de foncer dessus
physiquement si ginger est très curieux
de
palombes et risqueront est ce qu'on peut
parler à mon prochain chouchou s'il vous
plaît à me brûle à l'angle
est ce qu'on peut parler de tuer vous
qui ont
gelé venir de les unir je vais pas les
laisser jouer évidemment j'ai pris
ce couteau à 10 kg pour tuer recueillir
légal le prochain mac os porte en nba
le mètre cube
moi c'est moi c'est montjoie regarder
cette année
ici il est gros il est grand il fort il
est capable de serrer à trois points il
est méchant
c'est très méchant
et m'a surpris la série mais moi c'est
les mois mais défend le père il faut que
je parte ou psychopathe dans le moule
des
isa coco et là moi je vois un tueur kiel
un gag qui les outils justement pour
pour dominer physiquement et
psychologiquement on demand moi je suis
seul beaucoup de cas cette année
voilà la question que je me pose depuis
ce matin d'accord
ouais après le meilleur aux pas le
meilleur prospect ou parce que le meur
prospectus et même pas bancaire au cdj
écrit filmé
plus agréable à regarder et avant qu'ils
se plaisent c'était le favori au
chauffeur ce pic en 2022 donc avant qui
se blesse au genou qui au pied
et j fn c'est le fils du coach albi est
nombreux dans le moule et l'assistant
aux raptors trésor qu'ils jouaient super
agréable
il joue en plus si je vous donne même
pas kurtag le kelly joueur high school
qui jouait déjà avec jeremy roach à
shenzhen paul-fort froid et de la xe
connaissent un peu ce qu'ils voient
qu'ils savent jouer ensemble les deux
elva ouais il a en fait il a su faire ce
qu'il fallait premier match de la saison
madison square garden tout le monde te
regarde et d'efforts et tu domines et
après les gens vont avoir dans l'idée en
tête ce match toute l'année et c'est une
ère où le hauling sur le terrain c'est
pas que ça il a imaginé abîmé c3
et voit la défense sans porter elle est
très fort et c'est un des gens les plus
jeunes s'il se présente
steeve d'akoupé nom qui masque
juste sûr qu'il soit là la question
justement sur la durée c'est intéressant
c'est que des secousses étaient pas
aboutir à un 3 way compote voila voila
et du coup c'est vrai que moi je pars à
bord notamment à blake ce multiplex est
vraiment on peut jouer blakes justement
c'était plutôt à sortir à a3 et c'était
un expert un aspect dans lequel ils
devaient progresser 13h06 donc là il a
bien commencé la saison mais je veux
vraiment voir mois sur toute la saison
s'il n'y a pas de pourcentage
effectivement s'il est capable de tirer
là ça devient un vrai joueur c'est ça
sera impressionnant c'est à vous tirer
pour moi c'est premier tour
on regarde le qui alors comment est ce
que tu as des joueurs hors du coup
bah mon chouchou avec quel niveau à
georgia tech voila voila
j'ai enfin c'est très propre
techniquement c'est fluide c'est ça le
foot soit la ccl ya rien qui est qui
dépasse tout et technique bien fait ça
tire à trois facilement
des plongeurs prendre seulement ouais
ouais c'est toi et ça et arrêté deux
tirs il a raté deux tirs
effectivement ils abhorrent il va avoir
tous les tickets shoots soir le bar à
dos c'est vraiment pour lui donc très
j'espère juste que parce qu'en un peu
malheureusement le profil de prêter un
peu de laque biais de gars qui enchaîne
les dates des digues la nba la jei glen
bière alors que je pense que c'est ce
garçon traverse l'atlantique et que un
prince en euroligue c'est pour moi c'est
un joueur qui doit aller en euroligue et
dominer l'euroligue parce qu'il a un
même but qui nous relie en fait comment
genre un soin fabuleux roman de voir
jouer yes steve
soit tu restes tu sois tu t'en vas c'est
comme tu veux on va accueillir m g et f
dès qu'ils vont nous parler de big ten
salut les gars savent également des
gammes dont vous entends je vais fermer
ma porte
marega qui a réussi à las vegas
ap
on va voir on va voir un test qu'ovide
vraiment si j'ai survécu
je vous présente est vite fait mcgregor
donc c'est le photographe de michigan
des niveaux basket on est d'accord et
fdd qui est passé par un qi basket qui
est sûre avec les copains du café crème
aux sports cette année pour faire tout
le travail de draft
donc ils sont venus nous parler de big
ten parce que notre référent billiton
maxime n'était pas là donc c'est très
bien parce qu'on va voir d une
expérience terrain avec mme guégot
appuis je sais que faisais tu connais
bien aussi le système universitaire veux
que tu es passé à syracuse ça c'est ça
je suis passé assuré qu je suis très
content que ben est un l'année par les
deux quincy guerrier et de cavalerie et
humains d'aujourd'hui
sont plus cette fois malheureusement
mais malheureusement j'aimerais bien me
sens pas si
on répond par
mcgregor passe on va commencer avec toi
avec les prospects de michigan il y en a
quelques-uns même si hier ils ont été
assez salement battue ouais à certains
c'est un peu violent
j'ai un peu craint pour ma vie je vais
être honnête juste à côté du basket du
panier prendre les photos les tirs de
michigan n'était plus sur moi que dans
le panier ce
qui est assez rare en général je prends
un ballon dans un match tranquille hier
le mépris six ou sept c'est
vraiment une une soirée difficile pour
michigan à faut pas oublier que
l'arizona c'est l'équipe la plus grande
un vantail dans le championnat
aujourd'hui ea bomba michigan joue
beaucoup sur les big et forcément ils
ont joué contre une équipe qui est
beaucoup plus grande boucle qui les ont
beaucoup plus dominés
ils ont fait beaucoup de jobs reaching
sera moussa diabaté on va parler a
indiqué donc les pauvres
c'est leur entrée dans la raquette il se
faisait complètement écrasée par degas
et à et abat ils ont tenté d'aller sur
les extérieurs pour shooter à trois
points et je sais qu'il en a marqué deux
jours
c'était c'était assez le pire c'est
tu rates tes trois pintes et ouvert t'es
pas ouvert et fermé 6 des tirs
difficiles bon nom michigan ils ont raté
des tirs mais facile quoi donc je crois
que c'était une journée sans une soirée
100 à
100 fait beaucoup de beaucoup de turn
over 1 c'est un peu compliqué mais bon
moi je connais tu manges mais attendez
j'avais vu arizona jouer contre à
wichita vendredi et
arizona c'est l'équipe ea faudra compter
sur eux cette année ils sont vraiment
impressionnants
du coup tu as évoqué tout ça il ya une
ue stan qui a peu passé à côté aussi
fait un peu comme tout le monde mais lui
peut-être plus que les autres je ne sais
pas alors est-ce qu'on va recommencer
par akalé booste un art dont c'est pas
trop la prononciation a
dit les canadiens comment on dit ben
de dommages et toujours juste
mais
le gars le gall arena le songe à las
vegas il le col l'apn used and c'était
assez bizarre ici l échine l'appel ou ce
temps donc bon bref khaled à
calais pour l'instant son tir sas
offensivement c'est pas ça son tir et il
n'a pas des très bonnes statistiques
offensivement a maintenant ces tirs sont
pas forcément faciles jusqu'à maintenant
sa mécanique est très bonne elle reçoit
des ballons a même s'il est ouvert les
ballons qui reçoit sont pas forcément
les plus
serrées pour faire pour dire simplement
donc offensivement bon il va progresser
il faut qu'il progresse et michigan en a
besoin là où ça pose vraiment question
c'est défensivement
c'est un prospect qui vient de monter
vers des îles a été loué pour son clip
basket a partout tout le monde dit oui
c'est un mec qui a une intelligence de
jeu qui sans cette élite defender donc
une très bonne défense est
catastrophique il n'ya pas d'autre terme
j'ai 3 3 4 petites anecdotes déjà donc
c'était un tournoi donc c'était pas dans
un stade de l'université donc c'était
assez situent eux et on entend moins de
mou je suis placé j'entends très digeste
que disent les coaches à le coach de
l'arizona lz10 à ses joueurs les cfl et
ses housses temps ouvert
et sentir c'est un peu triste quoi juwan
howard était un pont sur le
bord du terrain gueuler sur lui c'est un
truc j'ai rarement vu ça
pour le premier match vendredi du
tournoi en début de match
jones brendan jones qui est peut-être
possiblement le plus mauvais joueur de
michigan dans la rotation était sur son
dos en permanence pour leur place et
voilà dit il n'est pas bien placé
pendant sa défense et et là tu t'es tu
as le plus mauvais joueur sur le terrain
globalement qui oblige il lui expliquez
vous ce plat c'est quoi c'est tout
n'existe ni c'est pas possible il a
ébloui que c'est un moment donné il a
attrapé par le col et a engueulé alors
bon il à y laisser leur seigneur de
l'équipe c'est les surnommait le prof ah
c'est un peu c'est un peu normal que
c'est un peu moins que ça soit il ay
books qui le fait c'est moins choquant
que ce soit
et hier pendant le match c'est moussa
c'est moussa qui est ou parle très bien
l'anglais mais c'est ça c'est pas sa
langue maternelle il est il est
fraîchement
et c'est moussa qui oblige le diriger
l'idée de se placer quoi c'est c'est
improbable honnêtement c'est improbable
à en vrai que s'améliorer maintenant
c'est pour donner l'idée catastrophique
mais l'ondé quoi est ce que bell bene
allen ça vous interpelle cette mauvaise
défense
ça vous avez vous avez déjà goûté au
passé puisque les poils outre ce qu'on
voit à la télé et ce qu'on voit en vrai
on peut aussi avoir des ressentis sont
bien bien différent donc je voudrais
vous inviter gars
by the soul u19 l'été dernier il y avait
l'air complètement de s'en [ __ ] les
valeurs de vouloir mettre juste plus de
pointe adversaires et spézet
c'est un bac d'eau c'était pas
top mais ce qui m'inquiète parce que 10
matchs des autres joueurs et de
l'entraîneur s'ils sont si ils sont
stressés au point de le guide su si le
moins bon joie de l'équipe sans
ce sens ce sens légitime de louis guay
là dessus c'est parce qu'il ya quelque
chose qui le courant qui passe pas en
plus il était peut-être un problème de
personnalité aussi à quelques ports
sas a fait ce qui est intéressant dans
les bourgs des matches
qui était temps de le voir des matchs
lie c'est que ces choses le langage
corporel long pour le voir à la télé
il est complètement perdue je vois il ya
des mouvements il s'est retourné
il ya sort au début du match donc moi
j'étais à côté du band arizona et il va
sur l'extérieur à gauche il se retourne
il s'arrête tout le monde en train de
bouger il s'arrête et il regarde les
joueurs et regarde et là tu as les deux
entraîneurs adjoints de ward et je pense
que c'est ça dit washington sadi qui se
lève jamais les deux systèmes et qui dit
mais mais qu'il faut ke au centre et h
peut-être des ventes et john ça devait
être la bonne garde non c'était il ay
brooks livebox lagarde et lui dit il a
le ballon en main et les blues sont
obligés de s'arrêter de prendre la balle
ketty mais vas-y bouge tout à battre
l'autre côté quoi
c'est c'est improbable c'est improbable
ses armes en vue ce à quoi j'ai rarement
vu sa
cote est cuit basket chamas et c'est
quelque chose parle beaucoup je trop
attendu pour ça il est attendu pour ça
donc on va voir il va s'adapter 1 en
plus monter vers des sa préparation les
codes louisiens et quand même un très
bon niveau enfin c'est vraiment très
je sais pas gérer pas dire c'est
inquiétant pour l'instant il reste
toujours le début de saison mais il ya
des grosses questions il ya vraiment des
grosses questions il est censé être un
one donne un michigan a pas beaucoup de
bonnes et donne dans son histoire
surtout sur les 20 dernières années
c'est iggy des esquisses d'un côté et
après faut aller sur glenn robinson tu
es a pour le coup il rappelle un petit
peu glenn robinson glenn robinson était
un peu paumé comme ça au début de sa
saison à michigan un peu la même
position d'ailleurs un peu un peu le
même type de joueur
non c'est inquiétant c'est inquiétant la
société pour michigan d'ailleurs
allen on n'a pas entendu sur houston
je trouve ça assez dur perso parce que
l'attak de michigan je pense que la plus
complexe c'est la plus belle à regarder
c'est ce qui est les cèpes juwan howard
pour moi c'est le plus beau de
basketball et mécène est dur à
comprendre il n'y a pas beaucoup de
l'équipe de ski fond n'est-ce pas une
pick and roll qui font des choses comme
ça donc je peux comprendre qu'il soit
peut-être un peu perdu le truc c'est que
houston i met pas dedans à trois points
sur le début d'année et que comme c'est
pas un excellent athlète comme il n'est
pas quand même de trop battre son
vis-à-vis en 1 contre 1 1 s'il en panne
l'adresse eelv a moins pesé il apprend
des tirs compliqué il va un peu fort
c'est là où je suis plutôt satisfait
c'est sa qualité de passes trouve
qu'elle est belle et bonne et c'était un
peu sous côté sous-évalué parce qu'il ya
un monde vert ne vais pas là-bas pour
créer ce qui est né mardi 19 passes tu
n'aimes ardossi sapera fois qu'il joue
sans réelle neymar dans sa vie donc je
pense qu'il tend un peu s'habituer c'est
le tir revient s'appeler tout de suite
beaucoup mieux mais c'est pas si les
gens pensent que les plus jeunes c'est
un arrière capable de secours et dans
plein de choses c'est pas ça c'est
surtout un shooter sa sont profondes
pour enchaîner avec
donc des débuts contrastés pour pour
khaled on va parler de moussa qui lui a
été très très bon le beh d'avant il
était omniprésent et qui a été un bain
comme tu l'as dit moi je début de match
est effectivement été une prise à deux
systèmes dès qu'ils avaient la balle
quasiment et j'ai trouvé qu'il est
parfum n'a pas trop trop à gérer ces
situations là je trouve que c'est plutôt
qu'avec quelques passe plutôt bien senti
qu'est ce que c'est et d'association en
bord trois voies non il
c'est un peu un peu tes soit le plus
mauvais des meilleurs ou le meilleur des
plus mauvais ouais la situation peu
comme ça à 1 pour les deux que ce soit
dans le voyaient même hunter qui est un
joueur de très haut niveau avec beaucoup
de mal donc voilà si l'auteur il a
beaucoup de mal on ne peut pas non plus
attendre énormément de diabaté dans la
défense de arizona et puis c'est une
défense extrêmement physique
ils font beaucoup de fautes il donne
beaucoup de coups c'est impressionnant
personnellement j'ai vu m contre oui
largement détesté arrêt je vais détester
arizona toute la saison quoi c'est pas
le c'est pas une équipe qui est
plaisante à photographe qui aurait bien
d'autres manquent demandes de ne pas
publier les photos ou les mecs qui donne
des coups de poing des choses comme ça
donc bon bah non non non non c'est
difficile à mousse en interview vendredi
soir après le match as il était un des
joueurs qui avaient été choisies parce
qu'il avait un très bon très bon très
bon match il l'avait annoncé et s'y
attendait un petit peu il a dit d'une
manière générale en collège comparé aux
as qu ça va plus vite c'est plus dur
c'est plus compliqué c'est plus rapide
c'est plus physique et il avait dit s'y
attendait s'y attendait d'être bougez
contre arizona clairement michigan se
doutait un petit peu que ça serait
arizona michigan la finale il avait déjà
préparé
ou de lausanne ont ils fait des bonds il
ya des bonnes idées il a des bonnes
inspirations à
défensivement il est impressionnant il
fait des petites fautes
que ce soit le machine semble depuis le
début de la saison il perd quelques
rebonds offensifs il fait quelques turn
over
mais quand ils perdent ballon et c'est
le premier à remonter le cours
rapidement il va à une vitesse il est
vraiment très rapide c'est brasser
et à c'est vraiment impressionnant à et
en plus il s'est vraiment bien s'en
servir extrêmement rapide
il a une très bonne attitude
des puissants quand il s'enflamme un
petit peu à bâle match vendredi soir il
s'est enflammé il a trois quatre minutes
où ils s'enflamment bien et puis bah oui
je fais son tir à trois points il le met
c'était assez marrant de voir médecin
tirs à trois points parce que j'avais
l'équipe de michigan qui est à côté de
moi le bon est en fait ils se sont tous
arrêtés ils ont même pas célébrer tout
de suite il y avait des cas 204
e été un peu surpris par tant que
doivent le voir et de juger les échos
comme quoi il aimait à l'entraînement
quoi mais à non ils s'adaptent très bien
très rapidement je parlais de brendan
jones qui est le plus mauvais de
l'équipe entre guillemets un tout et qui
est à starter mois depuis le début
depuis que diabaté a fait son annonce
officielle à michigan en sachant que
john serait le starter j'arrête pas dire
que qui va prendre 15 20 minutes par
match et à je disais et quelques jours à
bombe à peut-être janvier février va
être starter
j'en suis au point où je serais pas
surpris bon peut-être pas contre yohan
si la semaine prochaine mais san diego
en michigan va recevoir san diego en mi
décembre je serais pas surpris de voir
où ça a démarré le match je pense il en
est là c'est il est vraiment
impressionnant
au temps où ce temps on se disait bon
bah c'est one donne est maintenant en
train de se dire qu'on va peut-être
d'avoir deux ans à je pense pas que ça
va rester dedans
béné allen qu'est ce qu'on achète à
l'étagé du dessus toujours la même
question mais c'est important
l'arabie et la vitesse de pieds
incroyable la longueur capacité passe ta
vision et wayne choix capacité à
switcher ont trop fort et trop fort et
on sait en plus juwan howard il a
recruté quand ils se déplacent en grèce
pour le voir au film a eu 18 ans
petit-fils de france il était là et
diabaté a marché sur tout le monde c'est
en 2019 et voilà mais maria am dit on
voyait déjà qu'ils ont une équipe pleine
de prospects c'est le meilleur prospect
leader non il est je dis pas que le
prends loterie aujourd'hui mais il est
trop trop fort et puis ce qui va se
passer cécile michigan continuer à avoir
des joueurs qui sont pas au niveau le
réseau hybride qui est pas au niveau il
va avoir plus de minutes il va avoir
plus le ballon il va plus se montrer
quoi il ya ça aussi qu'il va qui va
jouer
il va avoir beaucoup de temps de jeu il
va l'opportunité de bien se montrer
et leino il est vraiment l'impression
que défensivement aussi défensivement
c'était
c'est hallucinant c'est c'est vraiment
vraiment impatient
marque merci on va passer à ld qui va
nous parler d'un petit meneur très très
fun du côté de l inria
en structure des autres effectivement de
récupérer l'eau très très fun alors
c'est un lot c'est un meneur portoricain
qu'on connaît bien en france
puisqu'on l'avait vu il ya en 2018 au
championnat du monde u17 ils avaient
emmené porto rico nous paraît donc la
plus grande nation bosquette en demi
finale contre l'équipe de france il
avait perdu contre c'est la génération
emballé dont
escazal ont
à l'époque été installé jusqu'en 2000
donc le connais depuis assez longtemps
c'est un sophomore et jouez bien l'année
dernière a highly noix aux côtés d'ayo
d'ozone qui a été drafté par les boules
cette année au niveau du profil poste 1
1 m 85 81 kg avec 94 envergure c'est
long c'est pas non plus le plus grand
mais 85 ans de plus très grand la
dernière comme j'ai dis avec ayo d'oslo
il sortait du banc il a été juste x men
of the year c'était vraiment le
energizer en sortie de banc
le mec qui rentrait vraiment pour
redynamiser cette équipe de l'inra qui
était une bonne équipe les nanars vendus
contre curieux la chicago de 80 de kart
wii et vous envoie à la suivre en
belgique il fait rêver donc forcément
cette année on attend on attend
davantage de responsabilités pour qu'au
belot qui devient de son héroïne
d'illinois c'est les créateurs principal
37% visage c'est monstrueux alors sept
français thierry que cette il ya un peu
amplifié par le fait que koffi coburn je
sais pas si vous vous rappelez le les
normes plus beau match qui devait donner
le transfert finalement n'a pas traîné
ce faire il est là mais il est suspendu
pendant trois matches il va il va
revenir au prochain match ce qui fait
que pour ses trois premiers matches soit
curbelo il a été un peu tout seul ça
c'est vu parce qu'il a fait beaucoup de
l amp ça c'est aussi parce qu'il a perdu
beaucoup de balles on va en reparler
après il joue sur l'ailé arrière aux
côtés de traîne fraser qui est un super
senior qui a utilisé sa ration d
éligibilité en plus qui tient aussi le
ballon mais pour l'instant pour
l'instant curbelo c'est un peu un peu
tout seul dans cette équipe dédiée moi
qui aie qui manque un peu de dynamisme
pour le profil rapidement les points
forts excellente création pour les
autres c'est parce que vous en penser
les gars mais c'est un des meilleurs
passeurs france 2 m de la nba cette
année il a une vision du jeu qui est
monstrueuse importe-t-il et les
américains ça a vraiment au dessus de la
moyenne c'est à dire qu'il voit très
bien les décalages qui sont qui sont
faits sur le terrain il a une très très
belle et curieux jeu concurrents sont
des êtres défensif qui peut essayer sur
un pick and roll voilà il est capable
d'exploiter le moindre décalage dans la
défense c'était déjà le cas l'année
dernière c'était meilleur passeur de sa
conférence avec 39% des six tués ce qui
est absolument axiaux
cette même capacité de lecture du jeu de
cartes mapping on la retrouve en défense
où il est un excellent défenseur ballon
pareil il voit très bien les rotations
icéo être placé il en tire très bien
dernière dernier fait en date on l'a vu
face à marquette ou mais un contre
énorme au niveau 4 il s'appelle il
arrive que faible il voit très bien la
passe à arriver il arrive à le contrer
presqu'au niveau du cercle défense
individuelle
c'est un moyen de l'ex mine de rien il a
une très bonne explosivité très bonne
mobilité latéral qui fait de lui un
défenseur sur l'homme de bon niveau est
très bas sur les options politiques
attaquent c'est très bien sur le sol
porta pour parler un petit peu de ce qui
fait tâche pour l'instant parce que
c'est quand même plus un joueur qui va
rester la loterie la création pour lui
même c'est toujours très limitée et pour
moi sa part de son aïeul qui est plus
qu'aléatoire j'ai jamais vu un petit
bout
sur un dribble louise dribble sur le
pied ou bien il veut il y fait un truc
qui fait beaucoup c'est celle sur les
écrans il était beaucoup de de spitz de
passer entre les portes du ciel ou
dédicacés david cozette ni pèlerins
nombre de balles qui inclut un calcul
sur ce monde raymond maîtrisé
et on arrive à son problème de turnover
5 pas essayer de moyenne cette année ils
étaient un petit peu plus l inverse mais
ça en corse et coburn 10 voire 15 5
pertes de balle de moyenne cette année
c'est monstrueux
le ratio assisteurs d'horreur sheitan
54.5 s'est passé pas fou c'est marrant
pas fou autre inquiétude c'est la
finition près du cercle qui reste une
question sont touchés il aérien était à
65 % près du cercle ce qui est très bien
mais je
n'achète pas forcément le push et près
du cercle et sur les finitions je trouve
assez limitées là dessus et enfin la
plus grosse inquiétude forcément il faut
une herse et son tir extérieur
à trois points communs comme sur les
longs tout c'est pour l'instant
inexistant selon lui faire sans lui
faire injure 5 sur 31 la seconde passée
pour l'instant mais il n'a pas encore
mis seulement sept tentatives
le mauvais point c'est que ni la
gestuelle un i lé pourcentage aux
lancers francs je vous laisserai nico
l'égérie guinée ne laisse présager pour
moi un développement spectaculaire de
son tiers et ça ça vous amène à poser la
question sur sa projection a signé et
finir là-dessus c'est quoi sa place en
ligne et pour un joueur qui certes est
un très bon passeur mais qui n'est pas
capable de créer les décalages par un sa
gravité de ce corps a en fait sans
menaces de scorer qu'est-ce qui peut
vraiment juste est ce qu'on peut
vraiment juste acheté ça
sur cinq avait cette année king c'est
son accession
est légal et j il a fait la question
pour moi et du nickel merci
j'accomplis ziane
c'est l'un des genres je pensais plus
cool à regarder mais dont il faut quand
même être sévère sur les points à
travailler qui font que ça pourrait
limiter ça
tu auras une bille et il faut qu'il tire
qu'il n'y a pas de souvenirs pas pour
moi y'a pas d'autre solution ou alors
c'est quoi tidiane mcconnell mais
contre à dire que tu dois jouer un
schéma très précis après avoir une ligne
nous sommes honnêtes qui pousse beaucoup
la balle qui joue très rapidement donc
je sais pas mais moi c'est un super
joueur il est trop trop fun à regarder
moi je le trouve trop trop cool tube
hello après voilà faut que la capacité
de tir elle vienne sur les pertes de
balle ouais il a fait beaucoup après des
fois c'est pas tout le temps de sa faute
quand il ya des jouets avec des joueurs
qui gagnaient moufter fois le surfing
wesh la carène que c'est pas toujours et
ça pas autrement parfois c'est l'écho et
parfois ils forcent les choses je pense
parce qu'il fait parler des sciences
qu'il est
bien appuyé je crois que ça va changer
qu'un coach de berne va revenir
au basket il avait une bonne dynamique
de mes moyens de bonne chimie avec lui
la lainière c'est
je trouve qu'ils font soucis au panier
beaucoup je pense à ça c'est un problème
on parlait de taille torrington à la
tente qui c'est le cas elle ne pense
jamais aux paniers ont toujours la
décision facile prend toujours la
décision sécurité urbaine c'est un peu
jeune arthur à chaque fois qu'ils
seraient au panier
mais si un jour justin lin chi chi en
paire de baskets ne leur gueule
je tue le voit justement dans ses
décisions sans le ballon je suis le plus
content que l'équipe se permet il y un
contre énorme
non dans le masters points 5 contre
marquette way et de pas supporter peut
supposer une franche comté normes moins
80 c'est pas je suppose optionnel il l'a
fait
physiquement par un juge peut qu'on veut
justement non plus ici qu'il faut se
faire malmener r'n'b il a le profil de
joie qui va avoir un statut dans le
championnat d'italie mais
oui oui je pense y trouve une manière
efficace
en pénétration à l'anneau
je crois qu il pas très
souvent deux ans maintenant aux meneurs
la sortie de bons plus à une bille est
assez probable bataille promet que c'est
dans les îles danoises et oui je pense
que je vois qui est un cui basket et
quelle culture basket vers un pedigree
basket aussi est-il profondément dans
son jus il ya quelque chose pour lui un
billet dépendant la situation tourne
depuis l'afrique email
mj tu l'avais vu tous les dernières
comptent michigan tu me disais en or
ouais j'aurais préféré pas d'avoir vu
[Musique]
ayew ayew c'est un peu mon joueur
préféré honnêtement faut pas que je dise
trop fort ce que les chutes de royal et
les voisins entendent
à hawaï au sein de mes joueurs préférés
je t'aimais dégoûté quand j'ai appris
qu'il était blessé pour venir jouer à
michigan donc l'illinois est survenu ici
et ayew était avec quatre qui avaient
ils avaient en plâtre ou quiche comme ça
et jaccottet est à j'avoue les dés tout
le monde les fans qui ça tout le monde
était en train de se dire on va détruire
on va déplorer linois ils ont pas ils
ont pas ayo et puis bah qu'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est que rebello qui est
rentré sur le terrain et honnêtement il
s'est fait un nom les gens ils s'étaient
même franchement il se passe dit on
aurait préféré pouvoir ua ue qui
jouaient pour
bello quoi
monter à la maison à la une dernière
michigan ils sont très dominant toute la
saison ah c'est le pire match qu'ils ont
fait quoi le pire match de michigan
dernière c à la maison et c'est pas con
tre illinois parce que cobourne avait
été quand même assez à un thérapeute
être pas mal maîtrisée relate le seconde
il joue du lay ouais c'est ça exactement
ah
ouais à cockburn avait été quand même
pas mal pas mal limité par enter au
niveau défense wagner l'avait bien pris
et puis ben ils n'ont pas réussi à tenir
il est très rapide il est très vif et
qu'il est très intelligent je trouve que
ce au niveau de la passe de plats du
placement à ses placements moi ça
m'avait impressionné et après bon là
c'est pareil de nouveaux mots je suis
sur le terrain j'ai une vision qui est
différente je suis sensé de les suivre
avec mon appareil photo et c'est
d'anticiper un petit peu ce qu'ils font
a et c est ma vie et pas dé quoi j'avais
terminé le match je crois que d'ailleurs
la page wikipedia c'est ma photo
parce qu'il m'avait mais il m'avait plu
quoi c'est un joueur qui m'a plu tout de
suite après voilà la peau le poste qui
nous il joue comme un vieux cd poste que
j'apprécie beaucoup des postes qui sont
six mois un peu aussi mais à mai mois
donc curbelo vraiment impressionnant
j'ai vraiment vraiment beaucoup
d'attentes en lui et ses statistiques
sont déjà assez bonnes sur le début de
saison
déjà il fait montre déjà il concrétise
déjà sa saison passée quoi
aider on va passer au dernier prospects
celui de nebraska magouilles je sais que
ray lane vous qu'on parle de vague ouais
tu croiras recul parfait je vais
commencer violent typhon se fera
c'est un mec qui est né dans le basket
je sais vous avez bien faire ça chez
envergure du coup j'ai fait un peu de
recherche de pellegrin
ses deux parents sondés sont des anciens
basketteurs au niveau universitaire son
frère on connaît puisqu'il joue aussi à
des brasses car sa première année la
france fer de peep-toe
voilà mais qui est né dans le basket il
a fait selon elle ces risques ou le chez
lui en caroline caroline du sud
gros profess inquiet toile qui arriva
nebraska ses premiers première recrue
cinq étoiles de l'histoire du programme
de m la river est une arête énorme
et on peut prédire que pour l'instant il
a déçu on va y revenir
pour le profil c'est un poste 2-3 c'est
un joueur au football
très longiligne il fait de maître pour
un petit 80 kg on arrive à devoir mettre
un petit peu de de muscles sur les eaux
très bon burger j'ai pas trouvé de deux
matchs extrait très précieuse mais il
est très longue il c'est un scoreur
naturel s'il a un potentiel de scoreur à
trois niveaux ayant rencontré les
flasques euros pour monter ça c'est sûr
avec des grosses sorties offensives
et on va y revenir là dessus mais le
problème de brest magot est présent pour
l'évaluation c'est qu'il a joué ce soir
des meilleurs au niveau assez
manqué de respect assez aléatoire est un
peu un peu compliqué surtout pour un
joueur comme brad may doan ce qui
en reste cool a beaucoup utilisé le fait
qu'il soit plus on tout le monde pouvoir
tirer au dessus de tout le monde et
pouvoir aller dominant sans forcément
créer de séparation savait il a été
capable de le faire face au mythe
medders ensuite il a joué creighton on
en parlait avant les équipes du big
liste des équipes de roubles à wil on
sait tous des mecs qui sont julie
rousseau format ou là il est passé à peu
près à côté il a mené 6 points et
c'était 3 dunk sur des coupes vous
n'avez pas eu beaucoup plus de mal à
créer assez
rapidement ils évoluent dans un système
très proche de ce qu'on vend en nba
s'explique par le fait que le coach et
ses traders
la légende daiwa states - la légende
deux des six clubs de boules la carte ce
qui est ce qu'ils proposent des
brassards à l'âme par les a vendus de
michigan avec journaux voire moi j'aime
beaucoup le devenir roi ce cas aussi il
ya du spen pick and roll c'est le il ya
une toute une panoplie de d'écran au
ballon qui fait que maïwenn c'est
utilisé dans un rôle à peu près proche
de ce qui pourrait être utilisé en nba
comme ça c'est intéressant pour
l'évaluation à l'autre contexte qui joue
avec beaucoup de gardes hopper classe
mêmes qui tiennent beaucoup le ballon
kobe webster alonso verges junior k qui
démarre réseau mastella qui la
transforment
rapidement rapidement sur son
profil très bonne percussion sur les
braves sur l'école parce qu'il est long
parce qu'il a un bon petit haendel est
capable une une séparation et surtout
les il a montré une très bonne capacité
rauque et des lancers francs il a
inscrit trois aigles qui est qu'il
montre que 51% j'avais noté sylvain
statique pendant que ça c'est très bon
les questions ça va être sur les sûr ça
défonce les outils défensif soit il est
très long
il a une explosivité et une mobilité da
terra qui sont bonnes pour l'instant il
manque d'implication et d'intensité ce
que ces décomptes crettol s'est aussi vu
dans des matchs contre les mines mais
d'ordre c'est un petit peu plus
compliqués à juger les moins et ça ça
vient souvent pour des freshman qui sont
dominants toute leur carrière et qui
avec tout de suite
d'annoncer la prise de décision comment
parler avant de caler houston c'était ça
si l'ex il arrive pas à créer sa
séparation il va vite revenir sur ce
qu'on répertoire d'être fièrement de tir
à mi-distance contestées et c'est vrai
que c'est l'axé un petit peu plus
compliqué pour l'instant difficile
d'analyser son début de saison entre
carton contre une adversité faible et
match de kristen wiig passé un peu à
côté la réalité de son niveau elle se
trouve sûrement entre les deux en tout
cas les flashs france ils sont là mais
il faudra montrer davantage s'affirmer
comme une valeur sûre d'octobre en
france
qu'est ce que vous aimez bien cet ailier
karski a un physique de nageurs et des
épaules un peu éclipsé la com ça d'après
sur peut-être le côté fin qui fit se
quitter sa haine
j'avais repéré et déjoué en school est
en fait j'avais vu qu'il avait comme
passe comment il avait commis tap le
rédacteur et
tous les joueurs qui comme états floride
a fait depuis trois quatre ans ça
m'intéresse parce que c'est une usine à
sortir des ailiers qui joue en nba et
puis bah il fait de m'être très bonne et
très mais comme tu l'as dit envergure
explosif est
en fait lui vraiment après on dit ça sur
tous les joueurs on parle du tir mais
lui c'est vraiment ça parce que s'il
peut pas tirer il négatif offensivement
et demi ici peut tirer
juste en spots à un sergent de rotation
même voire plus parce qu'il explique
annick non
pas mais j'achète le fait qui peut la
changer
en novembre 2002 est très jeune
je sais qu'une nebraska s'adressait
s'était pas peut-être pas forcément ce
qui va gagner beaucoup de matches mais
le projet d'un iceberg comme natif
d'istres est bien moderne et je pense
qu'ils aimeraient bien se lancer dans
une usine à prospecter
ici des joueurs qui veulent envoyer à
une biais ils ont évidemment vous le
font via via le portail des transferts
la rsa arrive à récupérer mois de goven
ce qui est de leurs grosses recrues de
tous les temps donc alors qu'il
travaille là dessus mais toute façon je
ne suis pas un docteur dit sur et les
spécialistes et côté des tirs il y en
aurait une binette et font du très bon
travail donc pour moi il devrait être
pris l'an prochain sans trop de soucis
si libre mes études ici à quel niveau à
quel niveau tu dis ouais ce gars là je
le prends premier arrêt j'ai un peu du
mal
à situer moi j'ai du mal mais des choix
afin d'y réfléchir brightman cause
jusqu'aux j'ai pas dans les choix tel
choix avant car des choses à la personne
de garde
et bellon jade et l'on serve mais oui
pour cette a7 au mois il ne fait pas
une vie trois fois champion nba
patrick mc à
l on
n'osait chiffres titrait moi j'aime
beaucoup mes gosses sa capacité
justement pas la page de sa bougie de
nord-sud à bouger est ouest les plus
corrosifs que mes cartes est peut-être
moins bon
- mon pass
comme comme on dit des puits
alain de travaux préparatifs savent à
100% par ses pensées si les veloppe
l'homme ondh est le moindrement
stable l'on va voir un jour on va voir
un joueur qui va être capable de
bonifier notation puis de besoins vrai
rôle à une bille vraiment parce que on
parle de jours ajoute un
petit progrès faits pékin foisonnent
l'allemand mince que si on peu longue
l'empêchent de série peut passer dans
des très petits espaces se rendre au
panier plots 0 pagny moi j'aime ma
gauche posent sont à 100% de caisse que
je voudrais avec un stand c'est clair
même définitivement un joueur à
surveiller
on va finir sur la big ten avec la watch
list les jours à a1 regarder où les
voies dont on n'a pas parlé la
f10 on va commencer ap après on
nous donnera la parole à alger son
caisson quelques joueurs que comme ça
dans cette conférence va regarder web et
mail benmeliani à max christie garde de
michigan par et l'on garde freshman qui
devrait beaucoup plus responsable était
pas un responsabilisé par les hommes qui
pour l'instant n'est pas trop et des
lidl de estate soldats au poste 4
juniors qui aurait pu se présenter à la
draft un maire et un petit poste 4 oui
petit post cap n'est post 4 costaud
dans la capacité à stretch bonne vision
du jeu je vais laisser les autres plus
gros pour mg mais sinon moi sur des mecs
un peu un peu plus loin il ya eric ayala
qui étaient des rares spécialistes de
marineland que j'aime bien
markus pinger du niort le grand de
michigan state on parle hélas moins de
viande au poste 5 ça va mais mais il ya
de la viande et j'aime bien sa longueur
voilà le marcus grosbill et qu'il de
michigan state
mg
en parlant de michigan state je pense
qu'il faut pas il ya un gars qu'il faut
commencer à regarder un petit peu c'est
assez
régulièrement acquis et jordan nike inc
qui est le point guard à
il a pas beaucoup de minutes pour
l'instant mais les échos après moi c'est
toujours pareil l'excusé les échos du
terrain les les échos des autres joueurs
et il est vraiment impressionnant tout
le monde est vraiment impressionné par
lui donc john gillies je pense que c'est
un jeu il va falloir regarder quand il
rentre il ya ivy jaden a heavy a perdu
la vie
ce que tout le monde parle de john
williams a perdu je pense que avis aussi
un très bon joueur une meilleure général
perdu cette année c'est l'équipe a
regardé depuis forcément j'aime est un
autre jour de michigan avec un franck et
collins qui était blessé donc y'a pas
beaucoup beaucoup joué il en est qu'à sa
2e 2e match je crois cette année et il a
montré beaucoup de qualité de passe on
va vous parler de la difficulté du jeu
avec avec joe owen et d'intégrer le jeu
surtout en tant que langue à un garde
dont la face à face entre jeu avec
michigan et à francky collins déjà il
est physiquement il est impressionnant
et il me rappelle il me rappelle iggy
bradesco
liquière il avait déjà vingt ans vingt
piges koivu et l'arrivée c'est qu'il est
très impressionnant ce qu'il n'avait pas
dix neuf communes s'il est vraiment et
les stocks les prénoms de massifs et
puis j'aime vraiment sont il a vraiment
un bon look sur les passes il a tu sens
qu'il avait vraiment une bonne qualité
pas c'est je suis assez je suis assez
excité de voir où ça va ça va avancer
les gars va revenir un petit peu sûr
ravi parce que c'est quand même un des
prospects ou parle le plus sur le draff
twitter
c'est celui dont la comparaison est avec
un voilier et objets souvenirs des
convois veut on pense à un joueur et je
pense qu on porte tous aux mêmes devoirs
qui joue au brésil est d'accord
comment il me semble
comment il bougeait un peu plus gros que
djawad
physiquement par là il lui ressemble une
chance absolument folle il est capable
de fait que ses adversaires
j'ai rarement vu plein de joueurs
extrêmement dynamique bon manieur de
ballon aussi prend les décisions
responsables race et quick pielmeier
j'aime beaucoup
d'espoir pour perdue ou mais cette année
ça m'a l'air très intéressant il ya
aussi
acquis dit le petit pivot canadien de
fif est
monstrueuse
il est bon sur une major de lundi
à wil et il est noble donc moi je suis
vraiment très excité de 2,7
je suis très excitée d'être clash la
peau
et d'autres mousquetaires rapidement
vas-y à la brigade qui gagnent murray
est un des meilleurs joueurs de big ten
ouais john piquette penn state l'ancien
du sénat c'est ce que je vais dire qu'on
aimait beaucoup quand j'étais à senna
john allan davis qui était aux filles
aux fidèles 19 avec le team usa qui joue
house consignes et je crois que c'est à
peu près tout ce que j'avais noté me
demande d'en avoir d'autres et si
jackson davis
ouais ouais pas trop pour la nba plus
pour les sièges
mais ça va être intéressant de voir
comment ayouba ayew 5 ça va être
vraiment une question cette année de
management by le meilleur prospect ayew
pour moi de digne à la cetam arbitres
qui joua qui joue à rien dit il ya un
runner quand je venais resserre votre
coeur on va s'attarder un peu sur kijiji
parce que on avait une question sur sa
sur le sur le twitt
est-ce que ça va om billets ou pas votre
avis est ce que ça vous a dit non
mg kg par an non
nouvel essai
jackson délices de l'indiana
non ou alors c'est un vrai top niveau
qui joue dix quinze minutes mais ou
alors on va falloir par sigma comment
mike goodson le fait progresser mais des
soucis aux tirs et j'ai beaucoup de post
up beaucoup de postes en fait c'est
qu'il n'est pas né voit à la bonne
époque ouais voilà personne moi aussi un
jour comme ça un joueur qui aura dû
était là il ya vingt ans et
malheureusement
c'est puis ça mais
c'est un autre joueur acquis et panel à
l'époque il va fournir tous les soirs
parce qu'il est là pour ça mais tu as
marre bates par contre ossun d'ayem dix
ans un coéquipier moussa diabaté
fournissez à indiana qui avait commis
d'afexa ce et yannick qui a dit non à
texas parce qu'ils avaient bien leur
coach lui c'est un vrai pro spending
messieurs on se fait deux heures et demi
qu'on est ensemble déjà on va finir avec
l'époux de choeur de belle et à la ddt
vous n'avez quelques nous a tout donné
en plus et après on terminera sur sa qui
veut commencer ben wallace
et met pas beaucoup allaitement moi mais
j'avais alabama je peux kalaba massenet
est une équipe très agréable à regarder
on a près de 10 des dessins en début de
haute qualité de chaque incident est de
retour à la barre mais il ya un petit
niveau canadien un peu brutale s'appelle
charles bediako aussi
intéressant la barbarie mineurs
j'ai vu un peu d'entre eux dans les
soucis dans un match candiac du coup
j'ai quoi précise un espace de laser
sous-alimentées qui se passe entre les
joueurs la défense il est minuscule et
d'une rapidité complètement ridicule
non on n'a pas un peu de ce quartier
bout et moi sommes vraiment j'aime
vraiment son profil bénédicte mature
à resona quitte plus le les poires et le
futur québec au
futur du québec ou
au basket
sinon gonzaga grande foi sont remplies
de joueurs qui sont eux plus
intrigant il ya un jude un mort est
encore l'outil mis son grain s'il ya
beaucoup de noms à garder cette année
voit la
patte baldwin
enfin quid du oui enfin domine qui a
décidé de m'engager avec son papa will
hunting milwaukee donc dans la laure is
only il a fait un de ses matches et plus
quand une des plus grosse adversité et
c'est à florida la semaine dernière je
pense que faut pas surévaluer ce qu'on a
vu sept des huit meilleurs joueurs du
match c'était dans l'autre équipe donc
en fait c'est un peu compliqué d'être
bon ou efficace dans ces cas là mais
c'est un la capacité de choc making pour
moi elle est impressionnante pour son sa
taille et c'est un super super joueur
évident à prendre un peu de max christie
j'adore ma christie je leur en loterie
actuellement le jour du michigan state
qui était qu'on connaît depuis longtemps
inactive mais c'est en du cese déjà
là je pense que potentiellement meilleur
shooteur d'accueil pour les jeunes des
jeunes joueurs tels que les pôles
scruggs on a parlé tout à l'heure mais
pardon parce que vous aviez moi c'est un
des meilleurs joueurs du championnat à
son âge et puis
c'est pas tout on n'a pas eu tellement
de joueurs donc attaque beaucoup parlé
de beaucoup donc on en a assez
une junior de job parce que parce que
pour moi s'ils se blessent pas
il ya deux ans il se blesse au genou il
me laisse être et au pied donc quel
genre de duke c'est le meilleur jour de
la draft ya deux ans dans la catégorie
d'âge c'était le meilleur joueur de
champ qui était plus impressionnant
c'était deux leaders de simyo effet 1016
avec son son lycée en a un et à new york
c'est hyper impressionnant et là on voit
qu'ils ont les flashs sont là mais on
voit qu'il ya encore très trop confiance
en lui en son corps mais ça reste un
prospect cinq étoiles de très très haut
très haut niveau et puis challenge
orange money bates parce que memphis
ouais avec mérite d'être regardée pour
ces deux jours là j'ai une durée nikki
d'un choc beaucoup ce que j'ai vu de
challenge orange cada une durée qui n'a
pas pas normal qu'ils aient 17 ans avec
le clic qui offre
et money bates tri et j'en suis assez
heureux fait taire pas mal de critiques
sur son jeu parce que quand il est quand
il peut être bien calé avec un coach qui
sait bien de mettre en avant on voit que
c'est pas juste un score et c'est très
bien et c'est le joueur le plus jeune je
crois de pêche basketball sané ou un des
plus jeunes donc ces prêts moins de 100
g en propre pour voyager qu'ils
demandent marcus teisseire premier
premier tour ça sert le shooteur de
houston vers un peu petit mais vous
répond me remercier marcus affaires
comme étant à leur sujet et à 35 45
ouais mais ou peut-être même pas la
drogue quand on sait pas mais vrai vrai
bon joueur il a avec les départs de deux
continuera même ceux des jeunes jarreau
il a beaucoup plu autres sa vitesse et
son équipe puis avec minsk a transféré à
fsu aussi
aimé j'ai évité vu que vous êtes encore
inscrits y est vous avez des nos bouts
de gars que vous aimez bien votre des
petits chouchous oui moi j'en ai un j'en
ai un mais la proposante
et unième et je suis désolé pour mgm et
c'est cet oubli deux
énormes
que j'aime beaucoup et je suis désolé de
le rappeler ses traumatismes
et s'en va mais dans les
noix risona arizona tous les joueurs
sont vraiment chez moi j'ai les locaux
est très bon
c'est pas très bon c'était vraiment
impressionnant il a un jeu c'est pas
juste moi je voulais savoir koloko l'air
dans une envergure incroyable ce garçon
je
n'avais eu de mal à tenir hier avant le
match je suis dans l'hôtel suivant le
même hôtel que les joueurs et je me
retrouve dans l'ascenseur avec aux
locaux et je mens pas il avait la tête
comme ça
ça
d'ascenseur géant qu'il était comme ça
dans la
vie
sur le terrain mais bon je suis au sol
mais la chine en baisse c'est un truc de
ouf
j'ai pas souvenir de la croisade peco si
grand dans ma vie quoi c'était la cage
d'ascenseur est trop petit
et qu'aucun gros coup de coeur
j'aime beaucoup à m'bala il s'est un peu
raté
j'ai compté deux buts alloués tyson
etienne où j'étais à bordeaux il est bon
les gens aiment bien
excusez moi je me suis
une tripotée ça va continuer vous parlez
de calais blog je le vois là ce naufrage
annoncé
[Musique]
une dernière question de paul mc salo et
smith comme on dit ils n'auraient pas le
profit pour tout fracassé en ligue
adriatique
on y retrouve au clairement mais les
autres oui oui oui oui
joueur le plus utile à l'accueil et à
kayes et apparement celui d'être achevé
non non et encore il arrive aux pipots
d'halliche voit on pas le dit le joueur
avec le plus haut plafond ça ça mérite
une émission d'une heure donc
peut-être bien que oui
peut-être même installées dans la torche
et d'ailleurs
on ira on y répondra ultérieurement mais
promis on essaiera de le faire
messieurs ça fait presque deux heures 35
qu'on est là je vous propose est même
plus que ça c'est 2h37 je vous propose
qu'on s'arrête là
m g et f d merci beaucoup d'être passé
c'était vraiment cool d'avoir aussi un
autre écho parce que si nous avions donc
tu as aidé super merci bon ben elle
c'était impeccable comme d'habitude on
va faire un shoot out à toute la team
envergure tous ceux qui sont dans
l'ombre et je vous conseille aussi de
vous abonner bien sûr ou twitter
envergure de il ya un article par jour
donc les derniers en date c'est sûr avec
magie de lui qu'il aime un petit peu
beaucoup un tuto pour lire les stats de
ben et une présentation dumesny veine de
la semaine avec le gonze haga et du ciel
par alex c'est le cas c'est l'article
d'aujourd'hui et c'est un match tu seras
anglais sur bing sport donc vous n'avez
pas de raison pour ne pas le voir on se
donne rendez vous d'ici un mois pour un
nouvel épisode d'ici là la halle qui est
partagée surtout prenez soin de vous à
bientôt les gens salut salut by savez ça
lui